Ladies and Gentlemen,
Dr Chris Ryan.
Hello America. Hello Christopher.
We were just talking about, uh,
the pussy whipped phenomenon.
We're talking about men who have
wives that answered their phones,
their cell phones. Not to be
helpful, like secretarial you. Hey,
let me get your phone. So I'm wondering
if there are, do to get off on that.
Oh yeah, they have a mommy that takes care
of him. This guy is kind of like that.
He, his wife, uh,
I called and it was the first time I'd
ever called him before off of this new
number and I think she
didn't have the number.
And so she answered it like
accusatory, like hello. He was like,
I was doing something wrong. I was selling
yourself dirty girl calling her man,
fuck is this. And I was just saying, hi,
I wished dirty girls called me. You just
got to put your number on the Internet.
They'll call you okay. Questions I
get, I get some dirty emails sometimes.
I prefer that. That's good cause
that you can control. Yeah.
And you don't know if you're
being catfished though
might be a right as long as
they're a nice picture. Give me
a fantasy. I'm reading a novel.
It's like you're reading the words of a
character that someone's created. Do it.
Well, you know, I don't care. I'm
never going to meet you anyhow.
And men would know what men
would actually be interested in.
Well that's the thing. I mean I had
to Bailey Jay on my podcast recently.
You know who she is? Yeah, she's coming
on mine. Oh good. She's, she's wonderful.
I really like her. And she was like, I
think she said her husband and straight.
Well let's explain who below. Sorry.
Yeah. Bailey. Jay's a trans woman.
A chick with a dick who doesn't give a
shit. What Pronoun you use. She does.
She got upset at Gavin McInnes because
Gavin was calling her a he did.
She really? Yeah cause that's
his words though with me. She,
cause I asked her about that and
she was like, I don't give a shit.
She was really relaxed and funny.
That's, see Gavin says that,
but there could have been some other
things because he was being a Dick,
you know,
very possible.
He's the only guy I've ever had in the
podcast where two of my friends called me
up after the podcast and when
that's not true, this guy,
this is not what happened.
Let me tell you a Kurt Metzger and Jim
Norton both called me complaining that
what he said wasn't true. So he's a, he's
an interesting cat that Gavin, you know,
he is [inaudible] name's
ringing. It rings a bell, but I,
I've got a picture of him
but I can't remember who,
he was one of the original founders of
vice and they call him the godfather of
the hipster movement
because he dresses like,
like a really sharp dressed guy from
like the 1940s or something like that.
It was like vests and ties and tailored
suits and he has this crazy facial hair.
Yeah, okay. I've seen that. Yeah.
Dresses really nice. And he's super,
he's on the right wing side of things,
like very conservative and a lot of ways.
And he became a Catholic when
he was like in his forties.
It's a lot of weird shit going
on with that. For a woman
who, was it one of those?
No,
he was already married with kids and he,
he described it.
It was a very weird thing.
He said that he was like looking at his
daughter's foot and he realized that his,
like he's looking at his daughter's heal.
He realized that there is a
God I'm sure given more time,
he would like to express himself a little
more clearly in that regard. But um,
I have a feeling that a lot of these,
a lot of these right wing people that are,
um, that go pro religion, the, where
it doesn't make sense where they're,
they're like super analytical and rational
and kind of calculated about other
things.
But then when it comes to religion,
they just completely give in
and don't question it. And just,
I feel like it's an affiliation thing.
I feel like if you want to
be affiliated with the right,
you have to be religious.
And I think that they recognize that and
so they support because they know that
if you do that,
if you blindly affiliate yourself with,
with religion and if you want to be
like sort of an ingrained in the right,
you kind of have to be religious is very
few people that are conservative or on
the right that are atheists or agnostics.
Right.
And you're right, there's much more
unity on the right and the left,
everybody's stabbing
each other in the back,
which is why assholes rule the world
essentially. They stick together and well,
it's disturbing to me.
And I've got some people coming up,
some interesting podcast guests
that are going to talk about,
and I talked about it with Dave Ruben
recently where he calls it and you know,
Dave's an interesting example because
he is a gay man who is a very,
he's across the board on a lot of
different issues. He's like, he's,
he's pro second amendment.
He's, you know, he's like,
he's relaxed and analytical and a,
he calls it the regressive left.
And he's like,
it's almost like they'd been fighting
against the right so long they've become
their own version of that.
They have been fighting against like
the religious right or the super ultra
conservative regressive, right. That
they've become the regressive left.
And I think he's got some
good points in that regard.
Yeah. Yeah. I, I, I try to
get away from thinking left.
Right. You know, because
to me it's more tolerant,
intolerance [inaudible] and you
know, since sex at dawn came out, I,
I expected a lot of
blowback from the right.
And actually most of the blowback we've
received has been from the left. Really?
Yeah. From, yeah, because all the
political correctness, you know,
you're a cisgendered white male with your,
you know, mansplaining, blah blah blah.
You know what mansplaining tell
people that don't know though.
It's like the, the arrogant guy who
explains everything, knows everything,
you know. Well, if you explain things
and you're a married man, mansplaining,
you know what I was thinking
about recently and I don't
want to get into like a
men's rights thing. You
know, cause I mean there's,
there's a lot to be said
there. But anyway, I was
thinking about man spreading.
You know what that is on
the subways and stuff. We
sit with your legs open, you take up too
much space. Here's the problem with that.
Hey, men are generally bigger
than women, be men have balls.
Where are we supposed to put our balls?
If you can't spread what your legs,
where do your balls go?
Well the idea is that you're
being rude though because you're,
you should like keep your boss compress
the people next to you aren't, you know,
they aren't in encroached upon.
But yeah,
tell you what my balls are getting
encroached upon and that's got a very
immediate effect.
I think that's true.
But the meanwhile the
seats are what they are.
And so for a very short amount of time,
just think of it as an exercise
in your inner thigh development.
Just keep them pinched and work on like
an isometric tension sort of a thing.
Yeah, I just think about it like
putting someone in my guard,
like I'm trying to hold a triangle,
right. To keep my legs closed. Well look,
I'll go with it.
If it becomes socially acceptable for me
to put my hand down my pants and pulled
my balls up before I crossed my legs,
you know, I think he's just do that.
Well I do do that, but you know,
it freaks. Then I shake their hand.
You should have like a ball grabbing
glove that you could just sort of snap.
I'm about to give myself a prostate
exams is only so that when I shake your
hand, you know? Yeah, yeah. It's, it's,
the design sucks.
The design of the male body,
like the balls in the
outside is really stupid.
I think it's the design of the
fucking seats. I'm fine with my balls.
Oh, that vulnerable. Yeah. From
A, from a fighter's perspective.
Yeah.
Too Bad.
The most vulnerable part of your body
next to your brain and they're, well,
you know why they're there. Right.
Keep it cool. Keep him cool. Right?
So that your boys are ready
to roll at a moment's notice.
You've always got I insects it done.
We say the external scrotum
is the equivalent of a beer.
Have a fridge in your garage full of
beer and he say you got a spare fridge is
always ready to go cause you never know
when the guys are coming over to watch
the game. You got to have a couple
of cases cool and ready to go. Right.
You can't just pop your nuts out when
you think about having sex later on that
night and like sperm cool off, but
still another shitty design. Like why,
why?
You know and it's on every animal.
Like every mammal has balls
in the outside. Well No,
not everyone like gorillas there in
the abdomen actually. Yeah. Yeah.
They have such tiny dicks.
Tiny little dicks and see that's why
because but the male gorillas twice the
size of the female, I didn't know
their balls were in their abdomen.
Chimps are hanging out, chimps are out,
bonobos are out and they're huge giant.
They're like chicken eggs. That's because
they're, the females are permissive Qa,
so you got to the balls
outside of the body.
That's an indication of female promiscuity
and I knew it was the size of the
testicles was indicator
of female promiscuity.
I didn't know the balls outside the body.
So ladies,
if you don't let God man's plating,
how about you stop being horse?
If you weren't, we won't man spread.
If you weren't holding around,
we wouldn't need our
ball's in the outside.
We could suck our balls
up into our abdomen.
If you girls just keep your
fucking leg shot. How about that?
Do you ever see a Yogi do
that? Oh No, they do that.
Their balls in the air boss if you seen
it. No, I don't think it exists. Jamie,
find out if a guy can
pull. Yeah, I read it too.
They used to be a thing about weight.
She root karate like wait, she rue guys,
supposedly they would have these Katas
and in the [inaudible] they would be able
to suck their balls up into their body
to to prevent them from getting kicked.
I've never seen it.
I feel like I would have saw it already.
A big fan of any ball sucking.
Actually none.
Well now cause it hurts.
Well if a girl does it gentle,
she's good at it and she's got like the
upward stroke stroking thing while she's
sucking on your sac.
It's not a bad check.
I've never popped a
woody on the show before.
Some gals have skin, that's all
I'm trying to say. The, you know,
it's like we're not all created equal.
Whether it's basketball or painting or
Dick Sucking. Where are the artists?
We started this we, you said something
about what? Never tried to follow the sun,
follow the breadcrumb role.
Because I mean for some reason,
five minutes ago of the thought I had the
thought like I remembered some gay guy
saying to me like gay guys give
better blowjobs and then women do.
Or maybe he was by,
oh we were talking about someone sending
you a letter catfishing you pretending
to be a woman when they're really a man.
Oh. And then you said if it's a dude,
he knows what gets you off.
That reminded me of this thing
and I was thinking like, yeah,
I'll bet I'll bet dude's give great.
Blowjobs I would imagine. Yeah.
And Women Lesbians report much higher
orgasmic frequency then straight women do.
And it's the same thing.
Right?
Or like a woman knows how to go down
on a woman where guys are just like,
I don't know what to
do. I blow on it. Yeah,
it makes sense.
But isn't that like a communication thing?
Like you tell people what you
like and why it feels good. Yeah.
Some people just not good at
communicating sexually. It's,
it's interesting because it's like one
of the few things that people can be like
really embarrassed about communicating
about what it's like people tell you what
kind of, what colors they like. You know,
I don't like a couch that's white by
car has got to be black, you know,
like weird rules when it comes
to like things that they enjoy.
But when it comes to sex,
they're really,
it's really hard for people to
express what they enjoy. Yeah.
I dinner last night with a sex therapist
and we were talking about that and
she's like, she was like, you
know, I've got people come in,
they've been married 25 years and they've
never talked about like what position
works, you know, or you know, that
she doesn't like it when you do that.
You've been doing it 25 years.
She gets off on this
con punch. Yeah, yeah. It is.
It's a weird thing. Sex, you know,
it's weird you wanting someone to touch
your body in a way that's pleasurable
and it really
is sort of ultimately based about
around reproduction. I mean,
that's what the whole feeling and
sensitivity is ultimately about naturally
the, and was, yeah.
I mean we argue in sex at dawn that that
in human sexuality got co-opted away
from reproduction towards social uses.
Yeah, definitely. Without a doubt. Yeah.
But originally you, right. I mean,
that's why the all the nerve endings are
there and you know, all that business.
But even that like you could argue that
the having it been co opted and having
it move away from just being
about reproductive, uh, the,
the,
the pleasure being tied into
being a reproductive mechanism.
It's still about reproductive
even if it's socially,
because in the social
thing it's one part of,
of greater pattern of things that set
in place to make sure that you have the
preferred mate, you know,
like socially as well.
Like seeing how someone interacts with
someone socially, seeing how someone,
all those things are like sort of set
up this like very complex dance of
interaction between men and women where
you're trying to figure out like what is
the best case scenario for someone that
you're going to get together with that
you're going to establish some sort of
a really intense relationship and bond
with. And the most intense at the,
ultimately, at least the, the most, um,
the most committed is having a child. You
have to take care of together, you know,
cause then you're not just committed to
it in a sense of I love you and you love
me, but now we have to take
care of people, you know?
And so now we have to sort of abandon our
own needs to take care of these people
as well.
And we've kind of gotten this position
by virtue of our being able to socially
jive with each other.
Yeah.
I,
I would argue and have argued
that in hunter gatherer times,
that sort of nuclear family thing
that you're positing the, you know,
mother,
father child is much more fluid.
And so women weren't really
that concerned about uh,
a mate in that sort of long term sense.
You're talking about like
tribal situations for teachers,
which is 95% or more of our
existence as a species. Right?
So it's, so what I argue in,
in sex at dawn is that it's,
there's more dispersed
responsibility for childcare.
That food is shared, that defense
is shared, everything shared.
And that really freaks out 20th century
and 21st century Western scientist
because it smacks of communism. You
know, but that's simply the fact.
If you look at hunter gatherers that still
exist or, um, you know, even Banabos,
right? One of the primates most
closely related to us, they share food,
very egalitarian, right? And, uh,
so I think that the,
the woman,
a woman's admiration for a man
isn't necessarily attraction
for the man.
So she might be fucking a dude who's
actually genetically more compatible with
her.
But you know,
she spends more time with another guy
and you see that played out in marriages
now, like a woman Mary, uh,
Hugh grant kind of dude,
but when she's ovulating showground
Fucker, Brad Pitt look into, you know,
square jaw testosterone
indications, right? Because the,
the vigor of his genetics,
it turns her on when she's on [inaudible],
when she's not ovulating,
she finds it kind of vulgar and
she's more into the other dude.
So like women's taste
is really interesting.
This woman,
uh,
tweeted something the other day and
I respond to as a really interesting,
she's an author and she was saying,
uh,
that women like men complain
that sometimes when men
and women are together for
a long periods of time that the woman
no longer wants to have sex, right?
She goes, well, why is it so obvious to
men that they want genetic diversity?
Right?
They want to spread their seed,
but when a woman is done with your DNA,
like she's already had kids with you,
she's going to want Dick from other dudes.
Like it makes sense that
she would want other DNA.
Like why would it be that she
would only want kids from one man?
And she said she googled it and
she couldn't find it anywhere.
And I think actually you and I had
discussed this once like this idea,
but it totally makes sense,
right?
Yeah, sure. I mean genetic
diversity is a big thing.
I think I just pulled out my
digit. Oh, that earplug. Um,
we'll figure it out Jamie.
It's just pop right in there.
I just moved my foot and something pumped.
Oh, it connects over there. Sorry folks.
No worries. No, I didn't even know
you can hear. I just heard a good,
crazy. Yeah. Um, what are
we talking about? The, uh,
genetic diversity. Yeah. Yeah. Did I
ever tell you about the, the goats study,
the goat sheep study?
And I'm going to great when it's in a,
it was took place in Scotland.
And do you need a light?
Um,
they wanted to understand this sort of
like how males and females differ in
their ad app. Adoptation
to, uh, like how they,
how they're,
how they imprint sexually.
So what they did was they took the babies,
all the babies born one year from the
sheep herd and put them in the goat herd
and then they took all the baby goats
and put them in the sheep herd. Oh yeah,
we did talk. We do it. So in the
end, the males were fixed, right?
They would only have sex with the
one that they had grown up with,
but the females were like, whatever, put
me with the goats, I'll fuck the goats,
the sheep, or if I was here
and I don't care. So there's,
there's just this fluidity in female
sexual response that in males you don't
have. And we talked, I
think last time I was on,
we talked about fetishes and how
like almost all fetishists are men.
Yeah. I'm going to get that
girl on. That's Sierra Cetera.
Sierra Lynch. Oh, you're
going to have her on.
I need to hear about the humiliation and
all this crazy shit that she has these
guys pay her to do. It just sounds so
bizarre. I need to hear about this.
But um, you know, like you're
talking about the porn star earlier.
Not this year is a porn star per se,
but she's so sweet and nice and like,
sure. You know, she's just really, she's
probably just unreal pressed as well,
you know? I mean, she's
just, her life is so bizarre.
And in comparison to the average person
that's sometimes I think we have all
these like self-imposed borders
that we put on our behavior.
And I think that's one of the
reasons why someone like her exists.
Like you're a release valve
for all this pressure, this,
this repression that a
lot of it is self imposed.
And so we try to find some sort of an
outlet for all their kinky weird shit that
that really builds up almost like a
residue of our mundane suppress society.
Yeah. And it builds up precisely
because it's repressed, right?
Like that's what this sex therapists last
night was saying to me, it's like if,
if people have a way
to express this energy,
then it doesn't become problematic because
it doesn't build up. It's, you know,
like if dude wants to dress up
in women's clothes or whatever,
and his wife's cool with it.
Like every once in a while he dresses up
and I'm like, okay, whatever. That's cool.
But if she would freak out, it starts
to become a big issue in his life.
Last time I was on, I think we
talked about, um, I had the,
have this theory of how some people have
like a homosexuality fetish as opposed
to being born homosexual.
Did I must have gotten 30 or 40 emails
from an after that saying too that to me,
I've never heard anyone
describe that. That's me. And
now I'm getting a lot of, um,
gotten several really moving emails from,
uh,
men who are attracted to kids
and what they're saying is like,
look, I, you know, I know you,
you sympathize with people who can't
help what they feel right. Which is true.
I feel this, I don't ever want to act
on it. I don't want to ever do anything,
but I can't tell anyone.
I can't go to a therapist because they
by law have to like turn me in the
culture. So like freaked about
anything around, you know,
sex and kids that we're shooting ourselves
in the foot because we're not giving
these guys away to,
to let some of that energy vent off.
We have to,
I think we have to admit that there's
something going on in the mind that causes
this and they have to figure out
what that is. We'll almost always,
it's guys who got abused themselves.
Did you, these guys say that?
Were they saying that? So what is
it when you get abused as a child,
I could trigger something in you and
then that that becomes attached to
sexuality. Yeah, I think, I mean, I'm,
I haven't done any research,
original research. I've
read a lot of papers, right?
So take it for what it's worth.
My
feeling is that it's like what we talked
about last time with fetishes that you
have, there's a developmental
period, uh, for boys,
somewhere between five and 10 years of
age where inexperience can imprint on you
permanently.
And so that could be expressed as like,
you need to smell latex to get
off, or you need to, you know,
be treated by humiliated by, you know,
by somebody like Sierra or, you know,
whatever it is. And, or it
could be you need to, like,
you want to have a sexual experience
with a man even though you're not gay
because you had that experience when
you were seven and that, you know,
imprinted on you. Um, and uh, so,
and that's what that goat sheep thing
is about, right? They wanted to say,
they wanted to understand like is
this a male mammalian thing? Right.
And so that's where they're looking at
different species where yeah, these males,
even though their goats,
they were with sheep when they came of
age sexually and for the rest of their
lives, they can only fuck shape,
you know? Well, what is it with
women then if it's a man,
a male mammalian thing,
because many women when they're young,
if they're sexually abused,
they associate sex with worth and they
become hypersexual at a very early age.
They've, they, they, they're more
prone to masturbating at an early age.
I,
I think that's more a psychological
with the males I think in,
and of course there are many
exceptions to what I'm saying,
but I think with males it's more just
a question of imprint. It's there.
You can't change it. So it might be
latex, it might be red, high heels,
it might be big tits or whatever.
And more of a fetish thing, right?
A fetish thing.
Whereas,
and so if you were
sexually abused as a kid,
the thing is,
all right,
you're a seven year old boy
and your priest Suck Your Dick,
right? It's, it's freaky. It's bizarre.
But it feels good because
those nerve endings are there,
no matter how weird the situation is,
there's a physiological pleasure
associated with it. So, and also,
when you're seven, you don't
know how weird it is. You
don't know what's going on,
right? You just know like, wow,
that felt great and this guy
likes me and I'm special.
And so it imprints on
a neurological level.
Whereas with girls, I think
what happens is, you know,
Daddy's really nice to
me when this happens.
Daddy really likes it when I do that,
and I love Daddy.
And so those sorts of connections
are made on the level of personality.
God Damn. Yeah, it's, it's
heavy. But I to deal with it,
we can't, can't push this side
isn't real. Right. Yeah. Right,
right. Yeah. Yeah. That is the
issue, right? Like how do you,
how do you mitigate that imprinting
when it comes to like how they interface
with society?
Like how do you,
how do you figure out a way
that you recognize the fact
that they do have this issue and this
issue was an imprinting issue because of
sexual molestation as a young
person and how do, how do you,
how do you deal with that and uh,
and somehow or another, I mean,
I wonder what, if anything
could fit. I mean, what,
I wonder if they've ever done
any studies on psychedelics,
like really intense ones,
like a boga and things along those lines,
like how that reacts to people or how
people react to that when they have those
kinds of issues. Well, I think
that's the way we need to,
to look,
because I mean,
I just finished writing a chapter on
psychedelics in this book I'm working on
now.
And one of the big points is that
psychedelics are really good for breaking
addiction and addictive behavior,
especially a booger. Right?
It bill is great because it's
so intense. Yeah. But I mean I,
Wasc is grades Psilocybin,
you know, different, but he,
vogue is famous for it.
The idea I think is that
these boundary disillusioning,
these boundary dissolving rather a
experiences are so intense that whatever
patterns you had that were there before,
they've sort of been dissolved for at
least at least a short period of time.
You know, I, I've, I've,
I was described a really
intense psychedelic experiences
as being like a reset
button. Like you're pressing
control, alt delete on your brain.
And then when your brain reboots,
you're left with a blank desktop with
one folder in it and that folders labeled
mild bullshit.
And then in that my old bullshit
folder with a think of it,
you have to decide like,
what do I do? Do I do? I, um,
look at this folder and look at it like
an outsider and just try to see what is
useful,
if anything,
about my old bullshit or do I fall
right back into these comfortable old
patterns because those are all I've known
for x amount of years of my life until
now.
I think for a lot of people,
they have these big experiences in these
big breakthrough moments and then they
go, I'm going to be new. I'm going
to be different. I'm gonna Change.
And then it's too uncomfortable.
And then there's too much time between
that experience and the next one.
And they slowly slide right back
into my old bullshit. Yeah. At least,
at least partially, you know,
at least in some way fall,
fall prey to the victim of the
patterns of, of, of their past.
That's why it's so cool
to have ritualized, uh,
sort of culturally approved use,
like the piety and the habitual Leanne's
right where every year they go to the
desert and as they're going out to gather
the piety every night around the fire,
they confess everything they've
done that year. That was wrong.
So they like cleanse themselves,
you know,
and then they take the pod and they
have that experience, which, you know,
I think that sort of sequential
ritual helps to seal in the changes,
the benefits, you know? Whereas with us
like, okay, you go to Peru, you do it,
you're back, you're back
in your old patterns. Yeah.
We've talked about this before. Rites of
passage, you know, rites of passage for,
for adults that I think that these
moments of celebration and ceremony that
sometimes they can be like
really beneficial because they,
they physically mark like
a big change in your life.
Like it makes this thing,
this new thing that becomes a
part of your life. It's just my,
my phone has decided to transcribe
everything I'm saying here. Look at this,
see what's going on here. I
must've said, Hey Siri. Wow.
Because look at this.
Yeah.
You sure the NSA isn't turning on?
Well, what are they going to do?
And they can just listen to the podcast
and then transcribe and let 'em, hey,
Siri has this new thing. Like,
like, watch, I'll show you
this. This is bizarre. Like,
I don't even, excuse me, I'm talking
when you're not on microphone, you fuck,
you're not Siri. Um, I can say it
into it and when I say it into it,
we'll call you like, Hey
Siri, call Chris Ryan.
My number is not going to come up as it.
Yeah. Which ones got more than one phone?
Oh, there's a bunch of
Ryan's. Chris Ryan, you fuck
writes Chris Ryan,
you fuck,
I mean Chris Ryan, the
first one. Douchebag.
Oh Bam. It is, it listened to me. I said,
think about all those words that I said,
the first one douche bag.
Like get figured out how to do that.
So I was on stage in a,
uh, the comedy store and I was
explaining how crazy phones are now.
So I said, I'm going to show you something
and time I made this recording and uh,
you know,
I record all my sets because I'm always
working on new material and blah, blah,
blah. So anyways, I'm on stage and I said,
now, watch this. I go, you know, Hey Siri,
call Brian Cowen. And so it starts
calling Brian Cowen while I'm onstage,
but I made a recording of this,
so I'm listening to recording in
my car as I'm driving. So my car,
my phone is playing in my car.
The recording through the Bluetooth
and it says in the recording,
hey Siri call Brian counts.
So while the recording's going on,
my fucking phone starts
calling Brian Cowen. Like how,
but that's an endless loop right? There
isn't endless. It's too poor. Brian.
And Chuck was getting all
these weird phone calls. Yeah,
it's a put it on airplane
mode so it doesn't work.
But how strange that you can
just talk to your phone now.
Like you need to have to press a
button anymore. Well, I got a nice, uh,
I mean Google has these new nexus phones.
I just ordered one.
And the main reason I ordered
it is they've also got this,
I forget what it's called,
f y or something.
It's a a plan that they only do with
their phones where it's 20 bucks a month,
unlimited
text and voice and then you pay, I
think it's 10 bucks a Gig for um, data,
you know,
but it automatically picks whatever
network is strongest where you are.
So it flips from Verizon at and t to
sprint, whatever. As you're moving,
as soon as you get home,
it automatically goes to your Wifi.
It always picks Wifi when possible.
Whoa.
So it's designed to keep your
bills as small as possible.
And here's why I got it.
It's the same all over the world.
So I don't have like I've always had
a Spanish phone, an American phone.
Then I got an unlocked phone with two
sim cards and then I have to switch and
then the Sim card expires. What? You know,
cause I haven't been to Spain for a
while and then it's a big fucking pain in
the ass.
This is like one phone around the world
and this is all through Google's all
through Google.
I guess Google has deals with
the various skynet dude there.
So terrifying. They're slowly but surely
buying up all these android companies,
they're buying up robotics companies are,
but they're working on artificial
intelligence and working on drivable cars.
Cars that drive themselves.
She,
yesterday they invited me to come and
speak at their headquarters and where the
fuck they going to ask for your DNA?
No, it's, you know what they do?
So they asked me to come and give a talk
and I'm like, fuck yeah, Google. Wow.
All right. And then we go back and
forth a few times and then there,
and then I said,
I'd like to bring my wife as well,
and she'd love to see the headquarters
and then it's like, oh, um, you,
we don't have a budget for travel.
Um,
can you fly yourself to San Francisco?
Google, does it have the fuck I'm
going to give a talk for free, right.
Giving you a day on my life and you
want me to pay my flight? Google.
You don't even have a flight.
Money guys have fucking spaceship money.
Exactly.
I mean,
I want to come under the seats as maybe
it was like some Google employee that
wasn't,
they weren't,
you know, they didn't get, well, that's
why I said, I mean, I said like, oh,
I thought this was an official Google
event. Right, and I don't have time.
You know, if it's a thing,
and he's like, no, this isn't
official event. And like, how
are you fucking kidding. I don't get
it. It's Google. That's so retarded.
That's unbelievably retarded.
The fact that they would think that that
would be okay, that you would just go,
yeah, I'll spend money for you.
Sure. Fly to this gigantic campus.
It's worth billions of dollars as you
siphon up all the world's resources and
develop the Uber Manch robot. Kim,
let me bring you lunch. You know,
how about I suck your Dick on there
too. I mean, I'm a man. I'm good at it.
That's my rose. I know it's done well.
You know, that was like the argument for,
there's a lot of these festivals
like south by southwest
and now that we're like,
they put on these gigantic festivals
and they don't pay the artists,
they don't have any money, but it's owned
by South West, like south by southwest,
like southwest airlines sponsoring the
whole thing and they don't even fly you
there. I'm like, you can't
fly me on your own airline
to your thing where you want me to
work for free because it's out of your
fucking mind. But because it's
like a big deal to be there,
a lot of people just say, I just want to
be a part of this. And they go anywhere.
Fair enough. But, and, and I, I'm sure
you get these pitches all the time.
What's this thing? Summit? Yeah,
same deal. Right? You know,
it's like up to the mountain or
go on the cruise or whatever.
But what pisses me off is they don't
tell you up front the first four or five
exchanges, you're under the impression
that this is a paying gig. Right.
And then when you've already talked about
dates and how great it's going to be
and the that it, ah, then it's like, oh,
buy and they make you bring up money.
You know, you've got an agent
who does it, but you know,
I was doing it myself and it's like,
you know,
we've been going back and forth and I have
to ask you like, you know, by the way,
I, you know, my standard fee is x. Oh no,
this is because you get to
meet all these great people.
You're charging money
for tickets. Like, yeah,
we'll have to pay to go to this
thing. Exactly. And I'm the attraction
they're paying so they can meet me.
Yeah.
So welcome to the future. Well,
there's a lot of that going on. I mean,
Jamie and I were just discussing that
actually before the show started about
these companies that are
trying to capitalize on
podcasts where they're coming
along, they're trying to take a piece of
the action and offer some non-existence
service.
It's going to connect to you with more
fans and in exchange for a piece of the
show.
And I'm like,
they're just banking on the fact that it
seems good because it's a big company.
Like there's something attached to being
attached to a big company when actually
the contrary is true. It's, it's, it's a
bad thing to be attached to a big company.
Then you have to meet with all these
people and they get to decide which
direction your shit goes in and like,
Ooh. And that's summit thing, man.
I got an email and I think,
I think you were in it.
It was a bunch of faces on the email.
Like are you on the website? Are you
well fucking hope not cause I, I
said no. Well I don't know man.
There was a lot of people that were on
it that I was looking at that was like,
what the fuck? You know, I was
looking at it and then I was like,
this seems like very strange.
Like there's a lot of people involved
in this thing. Hold on. Yeah.
Well they invited me to go on this
cruise, which is next week, I think.
And you know it,
it is like they've got a lot of heavy
hitters going on the cruise, right.
As you know, whatever. Not Presenters,
but it's like the CEO of Google
is going to be there and you know,
Mark Zuckerberg or somebody, I all kind
of people Hancock's on this thing, right?
Hmm. Yeah. Well if they told
him he thinks he's getting paid.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people in this thing.
It seemed like they should be getting
paid. I mean, this is a, it is,
it's a very impressive
lineup of human beings.
Yeah. Maybe they pay some of them and
I'm just like not in the pay grade,
you know?
I don't know.
Well, I don't know either, but
I mean, I guess it would kind of make
sense if it was free for everybody.
Well, if you, or if you're, you're,
you're not playing anymore is about like,
you need to like,
like let's say like Ted,
it does this too, right?
It's all the networking opportunity.
So if you're like a guy with an idea
and you need investors than fuck, yeah,
that's a great thing to do.
But if you're an entertainer,
you've got your own
audience. Like, I mean,
I'm not looking for billionaires
to listen to my podcast.
That's not really my
demographic, you know? Yeah.
So there's really nothing in it for me
unless the billionaire is interested.
But you know,
they're an individual at that one point
in time that just a person that might
happen to be rich, like Richard Branson
started listening to your podcast,
you wouldn't be bummed out.
I'm like, oh, that's cool.
He seems like an interesting guy.
Like it wouldn't be like,
what an awesome opportunity to network
and now pitch him my startup, you know?
And that's what a lot of these people
are doing. Whenever I hear that term,
you know, I'm involved in a
startup. I just want to run
in the opposite direction.
Just fucking flee.
I didn't even know what you just said.
I gotta get the fuck away from you before
you hit me with some emails about some
shit that I don't give a fuck about.
Yeah. Actually. I mean I bad mouth Ted,
but I did become very good friends with
the billionaire there. There you go.
And he's like, I've been on his yacht
the bunch of times and it's great.
And he network. And here's the
cool thing, this guy, I mean,
I don't know if he's a billionaire,
but he lives on 130 foot yacht. Okay.
Which is like,
it has a gym.
Well that alone is probably worth
hundreds of millions of dollars. Uh,
I don't know. I'm not
appointing yeah. Cars.
But this is like a Russian oligarch Kinda,
Ya know,
helicopter budge him on his yacht is a
gym. There's a sauna, there's a Jacuzzi,
there's a walk in freezers machines.
They're not falling machines. You wouldn't
want them rolling around. But anyway,
he made his money in wind farms,
so there's not even like bad Karma.
Oh yeah. He's just, and he's a really
nice guy. That's nice. Yeah. Yeah.
He's, he's funny. He's raping the wind,
stealing all our WIC and love to the wind.
All that fucking white man
taken all our wind. Yeah.
My Kid, uh, we were,
uh, driving yesterday.
She wanted to watch Peter Pan.
We won't see the movie the other day.
And the movie is a, it's pretty
cool. It's kind of intense, but, uh,
this is my youngest,
she's five and the movie was a little
freaked out for her little too freaky.
Like a lot of it was a lot of violence.
Even though it's like implied violence,
he kind of get it and scared her motto
mean people yelling big crocodile. Um,
so she wanted to watch
the cartoon instead.
So I put it on the cartoon and Peter
Pan, the cartoon is old as fuck. Right.
So I put it on and it is racist as fuck.
Like it's one of those
cartoons from like whenever,
I mean when did they make Peter
Pan? You know Jamie's name 19? Yeah,
it's a long ass time ago.
Um, but it's like they're,
they're going to war with the engines
in this, they're fighting engines.
What it does is say 53. Yeah. There you
go. Oh, I'm a little disappointed in them.
53 was a little bit more in line.
I was hoping it was like in the thirties.
Oh my God. Like, though,
you know, the, the what,
one of the songs and it was what
made the red man read, you know,
like it was just like,
Ooh,
what did your daughter notice
that it was racist chest idea.
She sees cartoons just go to zoning out
while we're driving or her little dance
class, you know, she's not
thinking about it. It just,
she's just looking at something that's
more interesting than being on the road.
Like I'm not a huge fan of sitting
the kids down in front of the TV,
but there's a lot of shows that are
educational and they actually learned from
him. If you could, uh,
could put on a good educational program
to actually pick up some stuff from it.
Some of the little kid shows that they
have today to have a little lessons of
the kid can learn about,
you know,
how to be nice and what's the benefit
about telling the truth when you made
mistakes and not getting upset
at people and that kind of stuff.
It's kind of cool, but uh, not those
old movies, those old movies just,
it's just racism the
whole after World War II,
there was a lot of weird shit
like paper in the Pew. I mean,
come on like French people staying
and it's a random, is it Crieve? Yeah.
Fucking cartoon character ever.
They never express why they never, they
never showed him fucking, and he was,
he's clinging and grabbing and
hugging and he just wanted to kiss
specking stinky rapist and
the w who is the other? The,
the Dudley do, right? Yeah.
That chick was always tied to the
railroad tracks was Dudley do. Right.
The Canadian, the Melty, he rode his
horse backwards. Oh, he wrote it.
And the lone ranger and Tonto. You
know what [inaudible] means in Spanish?
No idiot in Spanish, but native
American. What does it mean
as if there's one native American
language? Well, they have some variations,
but they have like similar words. I
think that there, I think the people,
the writers were fucking with us.
I think it was like Sammy Stott,
you know the Russian thing where you slip
it past the sensors because they don't
get it.
That makes sense.
Like the whole Batman and Robin
being a gay couple drink. Come on.
That's you know Hawaii
wonder the boy wonder. Yeah.
He was at the first
twink leave it to beaver,
but do they call it p
for back then beaver.
I actually looked this up and
I invite you to do it. Jamie,
I invite you to prove me wrong.
I looked up beaver and it went back to
like the 18 hundreds wow. Makes Sense.
Cause be for fun. We'll also and
grow. They weren't shaving. Yeah.
That just shows you what a profound
effect porn has had on our culture.
Because if you see a Bush today,
that's a girl is committed
to fucking shaking the,
she's going against the grain or she ages.
Yeah.
Or She's like Lebanese or something
like that. She can't help it.
She shaved a couple of days ago and she
didn't think she was gonna fuck today
you get the Vern fucking weeds
growing under her panties.
It is a weird thing though because
like until like, what was it, maybe 15,
20 years ago,
everybody had a bush.
They just grew up like playboy Bush man.
And now there's no Bush and
there's no nudes in playboy.
What's happening to this world? Fine.
Try find a girl today with asshole hair.
Right. Try it. Then I just
changing the, changing the DNA.
It's um,
it's a fascinating thing that porn has
literally changed the way girls groomed
their pubic hair is almost
universally like all my, I mean,
profound change,
like a percentage of change.
It's almost like 80,
probably like 80 or 90% of women have
done like at least some significant
grooming down there made.
Maybe they leave a little landing strip,
but let a full Bush go full
Bush was the norm. Right?
I don't know. I mean, I would assume.
Yeah, I would think so. I mean,
dudes weren't grown in right. When I
was in high school, I dated this girl.
She was crazy. And, um,
she was just all over the place and,
uh,
she was who I was like,
it was like,
it was two main girlfriends that I had
in high school and they're both very nice
girls.
There's not nothing bad to say about him,
but one of them went to Catholic school
and she was the most fucked up and she
just had just like massive suppression
from Catholic school and just looking for
an outlet.
And her outlet was any boy that like
showed her attention like it was,
it was good for me early on to like
date a girl who's like super promiscuous
because of like lowered my expectations
about what girls cheating on me or
cheating in general.
Like we kind of made some
sort of agreement somewhere
along the line that we'd
never be like official boyfriend and
girlfriend. We'd never be boring.
We just hooked up and fucked a lot.
Right. But, um, one time she, uh,
had broke up with this guy and, uh,
she came over to my house and, uh,
we're getting ready to do
it, but she wouldn't take
her pants off. And I go, why?
What's the matter? She goes, I'm
embarrassed. I go, why? She goes, oh,
my ex boyfriend made me shave my
vagina. I went, what? Let's see it.
Let's see what's going on down
there. I'm like, whoa, that's crazy.
Like she was embarrassed that I would
see it and like not see her Bush.
So it'd be like freaky,
like,
or that she would be some sort
of a pervert or a wack job.
But now it's like standard.
It's so strange.
Like I remember thinking like she
was embarrassed because another God,
I mean she was 18 she's embarrassed at
another guy had made her do this and then
I was going to see, and I was going
to think about this other guy, but
honestly, for whatever reason,
I've never been that guy.
I'm not like a jealous guy. Like in
that way, no. I'm like, who cares?
What do I give a fuck?
Especially a
girl that I wasn't even,
it wasn't like, yeah,
we were longtime boyfriend
and girlfriend or anything.
She's just this neighborhood freak
that I liked. She was a great person.
She's nice.
She wasn't bad,
but she just describing it
friends like she was like, uh,
you know how it kitten,
you could like roll a ball,
yarn in front of them and
they just have to dive on it.
That's how she was with Dick.
He's a role your dick in front of
her. Whatever reason, that poor girl,
she's everybody.
I think pretty much everybody who tried
to fuck her fuck her for a while at
least. I mean, I'm sure she
see, I think a girl like that
should be admired and honored,
you know? I mean, do you know
about the, what were they called?
The sacred prostitutes of Ancient
Greece sacred? No. Yeah, they,
they would, I'm every woman.
Uh, I think it was like a month.
Every woman at had a month in her life
where she would have to go and, um,
serve the gods of Greece by
being on the steps of the temple.
Fucking every man who, you
know, wanted to fuck her. Wow.
So really? Yeah. So her,
her sex like was seen as
her service to the gods.
And so they weren't whores.
They were doing the,
were doing God's work right there.
You know, that's fascinating.
And a lot of cultures have that,
like we talked about in, uh, in sex,
the time we talked about the
Kuleana I think, who like, um,
these men would go out on hunting
parties like four or five days, you know,
if you guys,
and a woman would go with
them to cook and, you know,
keep the camp good when
they're out hunting and fuck
them when they got back to
camp to like keep them comfortable.
And she wasn't some horror.
She was like a great woman. Like, Hey,
it's my turn. You know, and they'd,
it was an honored thing to
do. And that's, you know,
you're talking earlier about
like how our culture, you know,
we repress all this really natural
stuff and make it a problem when like,
why it doesn't need to be a problem.
I've always wondered why that is.
And I wonder if it has
anything to do with our, uh,
our need for innovation and for
growth and for productivity.
And if the idea of like somehow in
suppressing sexuality it makes people
concentrate on being more productive
and more successful so that way you can
kind of earn sex.
And if sex was more free,
you wouldn't get as much done.
And I wonder if it's some sort
of a weird work around that.
Almost like the construction of this
advanced civilization has sort of a,
it's like,
it's,
it's invented this path that
sort of ensures productivity.
And one of the best ways to do that is
to make people compete like in a very,
very, uh, efficient and v ferocious
way for the attention of women.
And if this attention of women
was like easily achieved,
there would be less ambition and there
would be less than so in, in a sense,
suppression like leads
to more materialism.
And that leads to a more obvious
expression of that materialism.
Like you want the big house,
you want the Nice Watch,
you want the nice shoes and the nice
clothes and in wanting all those things,
uh, you want all those things because
sex is like difficult to achieve.
And if sex was easy to achieve,
you'd be a little bit more
relaxed and your needs.
Because like ultimately the
physical needs kind of like Trump,
all the other stuff, you know, I could
do, do you want, do you want a nice watch?
Yeah. I mean it's okay. Why do
I want to, I swatched it will,
they kind of look cool. Okay.
But do you want a nice watch?
Because girls are gonna recognize it.
Yeah.
Well the girls don't give
a shit about a nice watch.
They just want to suck your Dick.
Wow. Well fuck that. Watch. Exactly.
Well you've just summarize the argument
of Freud's civilization and its
discontents well yeah,
that's what he says.
He says civilization is the product
of a repressed sexual energy being
redirected into productive activities.
Huh?
Well I've sort of reversed it.
I've reversed it.
Almost like civilization
itself. Yeah. Right. Because it,
because it's the result of that it wants
to continue in amplify that like any
system wants to persist.
Right.
So because it's the result of that,
then there are in built in mechanisms for
perpetuating that cycle of repression.
Redirection. You know, dangling
the carrot. I mean, if,
if capitalism could stop us from
breathing and then charge us for air,
they would, oh yeah, they're
doing it with water right now.
You can figure out how to get
that wind farm guy like you're,
you, you're using our air. Exactly.
You're making money on
exactly how that's right.
Well, I mean they've done it with land.
Right. Anything about it. Like, you know,
I'm going to have to pay for land
before no one had to pay for shelter.
That was free.
Well, have you ever heard the
argument about public lands? I mean,
there's a real issue right now with
this Chris Ryan. Fuck, not Chris Ryan,
Paul Ryan. Excuse me. You
have the Nice, the nice round,
which I apologize the Paul
Ryan is not in my phone. Um,
but that um,
in 2013,
he had proposed selling off public land
to pay for the debt that are corrupt.
Politicians have fucking established
and Spencer. Right, right. Well,
there is Teddy Roosevelt.
It's set aside all of these like national
parks and all this wildlife area.
That's an incredible,
because we could all go there.
I mean we have these areas of our
country that are owned by the citizens.
So like you can go to Yellowstone,
you can go to all these different national
state parks and national and state
parks and you can go fishing. You could
go fucking kayaking and go camping.
And there's politicians that have proposed
selling off all this potentially very
valuable land to large corporations to
pay off a lot of the tax debt or the,
um, um, um, deficit debt. The
problem with that is, first of all,
it's never going to pay it off because
we all fucking trillions of dollars.
Like they, they, they tried to
explain it that of every man,
woman and child in this country gave
every penny that they owe. We would,
they own, we would still be
trillions of dollars in debt.
Like it doesn't matter because it's debt
in dollars and we print dollars. Well,
and it's dead to who? Like who
do we owe it to? It's all us.
What is that?
It's a weird fucking,
it's just ensuring that we're going to
give them a disproportionate amount of
resources and and,
and Zeros and we already do that.
Public land is leased to mining companies
for nothing. Yeah, right. Nothing.
Nowhere near market value.
That's another thing that the right,
like almost universally does.
They almost universally support big
businesses that impede on public lands and
frack and do a lot of things that are
potentially damaging to the environment
and they, they're very submissive of that.
The very summit. Oh, what a few p a few,
a few wells get tainted,
a few,
a few lands get poisoned it.
There's a few areas where there's a spill.
I was invited,
but it's this weird sort of agreement.
There's an agreement with a lot of like
very confirmed right wing people that
you're going to be religious. You're
going to thank God. You're going to like,
whether or not you believe it or not,
you're going,
you want to align yourself
with these people.
You have to be openly religious and you
also have to be openly dismissive of
environmental concerns.
There's like this weird
thing and oftentimes it's
amongst people that are not
even wealthy. Not only are
they not wealthy, they have
no potential to be wealthy.
Joe The plumber, fucking soldiers manage
this fucking guy do Jujitsu with who a,
it seems like a nice guy,
but uh,
we're having this conversation once about
global warming and he starts going off
about these people that believe in global
warming and that he's just real right
wing as a soldier, you know, and he's
like, shit, like there's a natural cycle.
It's always been like, are you a climate
scientist? Like how are you so confident?
Do you know?
Like there's like thousands of scientists
that have been studying this for
decades and they're convinced to do
some shit going down and that it has a
direct relationship. It w whatever
percentage of that relationship is,
whether it's 5% or 6% or 1% but there
is a relationship between modern
industrialized civilization
and the warming of the planet.
Like they believe this is scientists that
have looked at the data and say, well,
maybe there's some cycle going on,
but that cycle may in fact be accentuated
by human beings and our activity and
we might be speeding this up along and
it might have this effect that is like,
uh, like this effect
where like, like there's,
there's some concerned about the polar
ice caps. Have you heard that concern?
That as they melt, they create
pools and as those pools reflect,
water exacerbates the situation and
everything goes in this exponential
rate and it starts instead of looking
at it like, oh, we're losing, yeah,
there's tipping points instead of loop.
We're losing x amount of feet per year.
We'll know.
We'll actually,
once it hits this area and then the
comes water and then the water reflects
light, then it gets even
warmer, then everything gets
crazy. Right. And then your,
your, you know, then there's gonna come
a point in time where you're fucked.
I mean,
one need not look very far to find
underwater civilization evidence in other
there, there, there was this, um, there's,
there's been a bunch of them that
they found recently with a, you know,
they'd go like near coastal
cities and they're out, you know,
scuba dive and then go, what the
fuck is this? And they find like, oh,
well 5,000 years ago this was the city
and now it's under water levels about 300
feet higher than it was 12,000 years
ago. Yeah. I mean there's some,
I'm sure there's all sorts of reasons
for that and I'm sure that's not,
that has nothing to do with industrialized
civilization because the ice agent,
yeah, yeah, exactly. But I mean
there's no, there's no question.
They understand the mechanism perfectly
of what's happening. But I'm with you.
I think the, the, I think it's
already too late, honestly. And See,
that's their next argument.
That's the argument that I can't really
argue with it because I think they're
right that, well, it's too late,
you know, because the methane,
that's what I'm worried about. You know,
about the methane. Yeah. From cow farts.
And Shit. No, no. In
the bottom of the ocean.
O and methane is much,
uh,
has a much greater impact than CO2,
then carbon.
And what does that from the bottom
of the ocean? What's that? Well,
it's human waste. Same thing as
the cow shit. It's uh, no, it's um,
plant material that sediment,
you know,
settled to the bottom long time ago. And
then because the temperatures very cold,
it's frozen so it's sealed in and as the
warmer water comes over and melts that
ice, like permafrost is also happening
in the Arctic, the permafrost is melting,
so all the shit that's been sealed
under ice is now coming up and it's all
decomposing plant materials.
So it's full of methane.
Well there was a article that I
tweeted the other day that's even more
terrifying.
They were talking about the potential
for long frozen viruses and bacteria that
we cannot control and that we don't
have any immunity. That's interesting.
Being released as global warming sort
of washes over these fucking dead wooly
mammoth carcasses and shit.
Some saber tooth tiger got saber tooth
tiger aids and it's gonna just get blown
off like dandelions in the,
in the breeze and it's going to fly
up your nose. And I mean, you know,
it's completely unsustainable.
The population growth.
I, there's a cool thing.
I've got this unread it.
Uh,
there's a tangentially speaking page
where people talk about the podcast and
whatever, friends of mine and stuff. So
there's the thing right now about, uh,
you where the guy's like, look,
Joe Rogan lives the perfect life,
right?
It's the perfect blend of,
of 21st century technology and primordial,
uh,
you know, life patterns. You know, he
kills his own meat. He has chickens,
he lives near a city, but he's
got land and space, you know,
so they sort of delineated
all these things, uh, about
your life. And he's like, oh,
how can everyone live that way? We need
to make a world where everyone lives.
Like Joe Rogan.
Well,
I don't think I could ever live
like this if a city didn't exist.
I don't think our live like, I mean,
I'd have to be off the grid, right?
So if I'm off the grid and
I'm gonna live the way I live,
I would have to figure out
a way to make a living.
So I'd have to have the kind of resources
that I have that which are really
dependent upon a city and technology
and the Internet. Yeah. I mean,
it really is impossible.
It's not possible for everybody
to live the way I'm living.
Not if there are 7 billion of us,
not if there's 20 million in Los
Angeles. Right. Just in this city.
I'm a fucking unique parasite. Yeah.
Well, what I'm saying is like, if,
if I think the key is dramatic reduction
of population because we've got the
technology right and we
understand how reproduction works,
so we could stop having
babies if we want to.
What do you think of the argument that
as technology increases and as people
become more and more,
um,
centrally located in cities and a that's
happening and all these urban areas and
these people will be more concerned with
their careers and that I've read that
there's a concern that the population
will actually decrease dramatically
because as people become more concerned
with their careers and more ingrained in
the civilized urban life,
that they'll be less unlikely,
less and less likely to breed.
Well,
it's well documented that as women get
more education and enter the workforce,
their fertility decreases. It also become
more, they have more testosterone, right?
I don't know. Yeah. I don't
know how familiar with that.
But they definitely have less kids for
your kids and they weight later in life
to start having kids and all
that. And they grow Dick's. Right?
They become like men and
mean. It may be a little, um,
but no, that's great. I mean, cause I
mean we're not, I'm not talking about,
you know, Carly Fiorina, I'm talking
about women in Pakistan, right?
Who have absolutely no power or anything.
So as they get educated and have
more access to resources and so on,
they'll have fewer kids. And a lot
of places in the world right now,
population growth is below zero.
Japan, Spain, France, you know,
the Nordic countries,
which is why the whole migration thing is,
there's a bit of a, uh, like a,
a bait and switch going on there because
they're complaining that they don't
want immigrants,
but they know they need immigrants because
there aren't enough young people to
support the old people.
That's so strange. Yeah.
But the problem is that they're getting
immigrants in a lot of times these
immigrants have like these really extreme
cultural values and right. I mean,
they have an issue with,
you know,
different religious factions battling it
out and all of these European countries
now, it was a giant Muslim
population and France and, you know,
have you ever seen that video where this
guy walks around Paris, dressed as a, a,
a Jew,
like very obvious Jewish person and he
walks through he's Arab neighborhoods and
just get fucking yelled at and screamed,
oh,
it's horrible to the antisemitism.
And, uh, I asked, uh,
Ari about it and he's like,
it's been pretty well documented that a
lot of these places that have a allowed,
uh,
pretty much anyone to immigrate to,
that they develop these communities
and in these communities,
they essentially hold on to some of the
worst aspects of wherever they're from.
And it's only part of the communities.
But if you go through those
parts of those communities,
you're going to find those people. Yeah,
sure. Yeah. It's, it's a tough one.
Cause I mean,
I'm generally pretty open to immigration.
I'm an immigrant and most of
the time I'm sure, you know,
my grandparents were immigrants.
You know,
anybody who's not open to immigration
in America, it's like, well,
where the fuck do you think you
came from? You know? I mean,
in my case I live in Spain,
even native Americans,
they came down the Bering
strait from Siberia, you know,
although that's being questioned.
Yeah.
They're finding they found a ruins in
South America that are about 40,000 years
old. Chile. I might, I might
be overestimating that, but
I think that's what it is.
Right? There's no way that was Bering
strait. So now they're thinking,
well, like I was saying earlier
about the diaspora from Africa,
it seems it's much more complicated
than the story of Bering Strait and then
spreading out from there. Cause
yeah, they came over in boats.
Well that was always an issue with the old
mech people. Right. Was it the old Mac?
I believe it was that they
have these ancient, uh,
heads they found in South
America our features,
they're very African features,
very thick lips and wide noses.
And they think that it's
Mexico. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And they think that it's very possible
that this is all Graham Hancock's area of
expertise and him and, uh, Randall
Carlson will beyond on the 19th.
And I'm really psyched about that.
That's always a mind bender of a podcast.
But Randall Carlson,
he's the meteor strike.
He fucking freaks me out with
evidence photographs and you know,
the core samples of how,
how radically the earth temperature
changed around 12,000 years ago.
And he believes that coexist
co [inaudible] that it
corresponds directly with
some sort of an asteroid will impact.
But one of his things when he said,
everyone's concerned about
global warming and he's like,
global warming is a real issue. No
doubt about it, but you know what?
The real issue is global cooling. He goes,
global cooling is far more terrifying.
If you look at human history,
the great periods of growth,
the great periods of education and
innovation, they all came with warmth.
Like whenever there's some cold,
whenever things freeze and shutdown,
that's a wrap. That's the life
killer or killers global cooling.
The glaciers in the last ice age,
right?
The glaciers were down to Minnesota
like all of Canada was under and all of
northern Europe.
Like down into France. Yeah, like to the
Pyrenees. Basically half of North America,
half of North America was
under a mile high sheet of ice.
Canada just didn't exist.
No fucking hockey. Hockey,
no Montreal, no beautiful
fringe girls. Nothing.
What's that shit with potatoes that
they put teens routine. Oh, poutine.
That's stuffs for Dick.
That's people that are trying to put
fat on cold weather food. Really Cozy.
That's God damn delicious. I saw,
actually I saw you in Vancouver.
I was just going to ask you
if you've been to Vancouver.
I saw your show that that's my favorite
city in and well I should say that it's
my favorite city all year round.
Whereas I really enjoy Toronto
when it's warm. It's cold.
It's hard. Canada, it's fucking awesome.
That is the number one place that I
would move outside the United States.
Like is Australia and Canada.
Those are the two spots that
you've heard from Dunkin. He's,
he's in Australia now. Is He really?
Yeah. He just went down like two days ago.
Cause cause that's why I contacted you
to do the shrimp parade thing. Right.
Cause I was going to be
an la that's right. Yeah.
We can't seem to organize
it when we're all together.
But Dunkin's become too successful.
Sabotaged his career,
hang around with him. Yeah. He used
to be available and no love, no duck.
And he is so good at podcasts and rants.
Yeah.
He loves it so much that he almost,
I think he loves it more
than even loves doing,
stand up those rants that he can just
freely go into when he does those live
podcasts. He's been doing a
lot of live podcasting. Well,
I did two of them with him,
but he never put them out.
I don't know where they are. He's holding
onto him. Yeah. Yeah, quite a while ago.
Really? That seems odd. He doesn't hold
on to podcast. That's so strange. Yeah.
Dude, I forgot to press
record. Fuck. They'll get bad.
Let's do it again. I remember when
we said we'll just act it out though.
Exactly. Australia is amazing
though. I fucking love it over there.
It's just too far. The flight is
just brutal. It's 16 hour flight. I,
I've only been there once and it was
because I was invited to speak at Sydney
Opera House in this thing they do.
That's like the Australian ted,
but they call it the, the
festival of dangerous ideas. Ooh,
I like it. Isn't that
great? I love it. And it's,
it's like the Anti Ted where Ted is all
like don't offend anyone and who let us
look at what you're going
to say and you know,
let's rehearse this seven times there.
They were like say
whatever the fuck you want.
We want people to like talk about it
and be provoked and like, you know,
no limit just to say what you want.
I appreciate that. Yeah. I think,
I think that's a sign
of a healthy culture.
Getting back to her saying earlier where
we pression causes the problem it's
trying to avoid by pressurizing it.
Well that's always been the knock on
Ted is that they try to control that
situation too much. They try to make
sure that the speakers all room together,
like a Eddie was saying that they made him
like room with some other
duties like ombre rich.
I want to get my own fucking hotel
room mantle when they busted his balls
because he came up to do your podcast
to promote his ted stuff, you know,
and they, they, they pulled him
off of the rest of the program.
It's just you can't do that with a
successful guy like him. Cause he's like,
what do I give a fuck?
Well and getting back to the other shit,
they don't pay their perform.
Exactly.
They didn't pay him and they made him
sleep in a room with some other dude.
Like it's the whole thing is fucking
Uber Bizarre. It's very strange.
But in doing that and like really see,
I understand what they're doing,
they're protecting their brand
because it's worth a lot of money now.
I mean they have a Ted podcast and they
have these ted talks and Tedx and the
website gets fucking insane amount of
traffic and they've become a corporation.
They become this corporate entity.
But when you respect someone,
like if you have someone like you and
they like your book and they like your
ideas, the more they can
just give you free reign,
the more it's going to be exciting.
Right?
Gonna let you express
yourself in an uncensored way.
You're going to get the full Chris Ryan
experience instead of like some bullshit
water down corporate version of
whatever the fuck your ideas would be.
Whatever palatable aspects of your ideas
they think they could sell to people.
Yeah, it's a strange, it's strange
thing. I mean, I feel like,
you know, they've got a huge
platform, you've got to respect that.
But on the other hand, you know, if I go
out and I fuck up, they could just say,
well, sorry Chris fucked up. It
doesn't have to reflect badly on them.
When you saw what happened
with Graham Hancock,
when the Graham Hancock put out his
thing and they were saying this,
all this pseudo science, they're
accusing of of pseudoscience and, and,
and you know, this, this
horrific idea of pseudoscience,
like let the guy express his
opinions and ideas. And it was,
it was about psychedelic drugs and it's
his thoughts on how it corresponds with
creativity and history and what,
you know,
how man sort of evolved and
emerged with psychedelic trucks.
It's not a unique opinion.
Not saying that it's not original,
it's not unique in that it's not cool
and interesting and that it's not,
he's not the only one that
thinks this. Sure. There's many,
many people that believe this,
and this is a common thought,
not just amongst people that are on
the fringe, but amongst scholars. Yeah.
There's a lot of people that
correlate and rightly so,
incredibly powerful
hallucinogenic experiences with
changing people's ideas and
minds.
And that corresponds to a big leaps of
creativity are big chances that people
take. Or like we were talking
about your friend, uh,
earlier today that was
a lawyer and you know,
it goes on this fucking psychedelic
trip and says, fuck this law shit.
I'm going to open up a float tank center
and I'm going to be a freak and happy.
Yeah, exactly. And you know,
there's a big thing now in silicon valley
with microdosing microdosing wa which
Lsd or suicide or whatever
it is. Um, because
of the creativity.
Yeah.
So like Steve Jobs said LSD was the
most important experience of his life.
Uh, Kary Mullis who invented
the DNA replication,
a credited to, uh, get
the PR, what is it? Pr?
Probably Mary's chain something
TCR or something like that. Yeah.
He's supposed to be crazy though. He's
an interesting dude. Yeah. He took his,
his Nobel money and just
surfs. Really? Yeah,
I met him at, at Ted actually.
Yeah, he's a, yeah, he was,
it was kind of irritating because I wanted
to shake his hand and say hello and,
but every time I saw him he was engaged
in the same argument with the same guy.
This one guy was just hounding
him and I don't remember,
I don't know if it was like chem trails
or it was like one of these things
and I kept thinking like, dude, just
like, you know, it's been two days.
Yeah. Yeah. What's more of this?
And I'm good. So, um, yeah,
the,
the surfing thing is another one of
those things like golf that I'm scared to
try and I don't necessarily think I
would get addicted to golf because I find
it's the,
what's ridiculous about it
is more appealing to mock
than it is a interesting to
walk, like the precision and the
accuracy and all the, you know, the,
the control that you have
to have over your movement,
your body to make that ball roll into
the hole. It's still the end of the day,
it's just a ball falling into a hole.
It's fucking stupid. And that said,
I'm hypocritical because I
play pool and I love that.
But I know I become addicted to that.
But the surfing thing is an addictive
it addictive thing that I'm scared of
because I think I would fucking
dive right into that shit.
Everybody that I talked to that
surfs the way they describe it,
I feel like it would be amazing.
But that's a really healthy thing to
be doing until the sharks come and bite
your Dick off, Chris Ryan, you just punch
it in the face. You're a trained fighter,
man.
Maybe I need to figure out how to get
strong enough where I can surf with chain
mail, like a shark proof suit and
just to get to be really yolked.
I tried surfing in Nicaragua.
I look how you said that when he got out,
go check out our, like you fit right in.
And I gave love. Yeah, it was perfect. Uh,
the perfect wave,
perfect place.
And there was this ex military American
dude who gave lessons. And like I'm at,
I'm in a cafe or something and he's like,
dude, I'll take you out. It's great.
It's where they filmed one of the
like survivor or one of those shows.
And um, yeah, he took
me out and it was this,
it was like the perfect baby wave.
It was maybe like two or three feet high,
perfect line coming in at just the right
angle. Like he couldn't fuck it up,
you know? And I just real
long board, which is really
easy. Longboards are better.
Yeah, well they're stable.
Right. And uh, I mean,
I'm such a fucking pussy man.
I like after like doing the push
up and get up on it, you know,
like 20 times I like my arms were
shaking and like my knees were shaking,
you know,
I'm not in great physical condition.
And finally I got up and I was like,
oh,
I'm standing and the waves moving me a
little bit and then I fell forward and
the board smacked me right
in the fucking forehead.
And I literally saw stars,
you know,
like I haven't since I was seven
and I wrecked my bike, you know,
like that kind of like whoa. And I'm
underwater and like, all right, that's,
you could die. Yeah. Yeah. You can hit
your head and died doing that shit. Oh,
do you see this? What's
going on there? I uh,
I was with this buddy of
mine at a firing range.
Oh, two weeks ago. Yourself.
I had blood running down my
face. It was, it was humiliating.
I've done a really, yeah, I myself,
once I scold myself once when I shot a
pig that was just scope myself right on
the nose. Oh, I cannot an
actual hunting situation.
I'll walk myself as better or worse. I
mean, there were a lot of like, okay,
wait a minute. White men laughing at me.
Here's why it's worse. I didn't, I scoped.
It's siting in my rifle
now that I reconsider.
I had a bandaid on when I shot the pig,
but I scoped myself shooting at a
target before shot the pig. Now that,
well that's what I,
my buddy was scoping in like he had a new,
he's an elk on her and he had
a new wind mag 300 right? Yeah.
So I was shooting is 30 odd six and
apparently I was doing pretty well and I
don't, maybe he was just humoring
me, but he was like, Hey,
I think this is firing a little high.
Can you take a shot cause you're,
you're really steady today. And
so I was like, okay, no problem.
And just like it just drove
right into my forehead.
If you get used to have 30 odd six is a
big difference between the kick of the
300 win Mag. That's a big
shell. I got one of those.
Is that what your monster thing is that
you took out the two rifles that are
like that around that one
of them's a 300 win mag.
The other one's a seven
millimeter Remington ultra mag,
which is basically real similar in size
and round. They're both big heavy rounds.
I shot the Moose with that fucker
right there. Where? That's right here.
It's a baby moose.
That's a Moose Moose.
They would call it like a Forkey was
900 pounds and it was a small one.
There's so big. Where were you? Canada?
My buddy shot one the same trip that
was probably six 700 pounds bigger.
It was so big.
He walked across it,
walked across the road and it literally
didn't look real like his walked in the
street in front of us,
like it was road the street,
but it was maybe 250 yards in
front of us in the road cheeses,
it was like Jurassic Park.
It was like a scene in Jurassic Park.
I mean we could have probably driven
under it with a truck we were in.
I'm not kidding.
There's so fucking big.
I remember seeing them in
Alaska and thinking they
were like horses on steroids.
Yeah, they're just a shoulder
front, shoulders. Incredible.
With barn doors growing out of the
side of their heads. They're monstrous,
monstrous animals.
You know,
there's an idea that's connected with
the cold weather and large mammals like
that, that the colder the
weather, the larger the Mammo,
I forget what the principle
is. It's skin exposure. Yeah,
bigger internal and less skin
exposure. The ratio, the ratio,
because the same animals that are
enormous in like Saskatchewan,
like white tailed deer. If they're
in Mexico, they're way smaller,
like a big white tail deer.
In Mexico it was only like a
hundred and something pounds.
Whereas in Saskatchewan
they'll get to 300 plus pounds.
They're literally like three times as big.
Same species. Yeah. Same species. Yeah.
That's what also why polar bears are
so fucking big that polar bears are
gigantic. You know, Kodiak bears
on, um, we've been to Kodiak, man,
I've seen one day I was sitting
on a bridge. It was weird.
I was sitting on this bridge. I'd gone
for a walk and it's like a low, you know,
dirt board kind of bridge, you know, and
I sit in their writing in my journal,
the pedantic dickhead. I was like, you
know, poetry about Alaska or something.
And I heard the splashing in the river
below and I turned to look and I'm like,
maybe 15 feet above the water and I
look below and there's this fucking bear
down. They're like knocking salmon around,
like on the documentaries. Oh my God.
I immediately, I had like this, you know,
bugs bunny image of him chasing me and
me running down and then, you know,
whatever.
He didn't even notice me or,
or it didn't give a shit. Yeah.
Apparently on Kodiak island,
even though they're so enormous,
those bears are so terrifying.
There's very few negative interactions
with human beings and that's one of the
reasons why some people thought
that that show the hunt,
I don't know if you saw it,
it was a show that was on,
I think it was on discovery
or one of those networks.
What history? Just recently.
Yeah, it was Jonny Hughes did that.
Who's Johnny? He's, he's a guy.
He's a writer. I know at, in fact,
maybe I told this story on your podcast
about when he was in new new New Guinea
and he brought those people back,
the natives back to London.
Does that ring a bell? Anyway, I'm
interrupting. You rang a bell going with,
you're trying to remember what it was.
It was a hosted by or narrated
by the lead singer of Metallica.
James Hatfield and it was about taking
grizzly hunters to this one island in
Alaska that has the largest brown bears
in the world. They're fucking in Norris,
Kodiak, Kodiak island. And but the
thing is they're just eating fish. Yeah.
Fish and beached whales.
That's another thing they eat.
They beached whale can a whale
dies and washed up on the beach.
They'll eat that fucking whale for
weeks and weeks. They're disgusting.
I looked at leat that rotten stinky whale
like yeah cause it's easier to digest
French. Yeah. They just get
like cheese and like they,
that's why you can play dead with
grizzlies but not black really
can't play dead with black
parents. Well what I've, you know,
look it up until he just start going to
be careful with bullshit I come up with
here.
Yeah.
What I've been told is that black
bears just eat you fresh grizzly bears.
We'll throw some dirt over here and come
back a week later because they like it
rotten.
That makes sense.
Unless they're super hungry at the time
and they just gorge your guts and then
slowly, that's one of the things they
do is they always eat the guts first.
And women, you know about the
thing with women with the pussy,
if they're having a period.
Yeah, it's really terrible.
Way To die first for the bear.
Have you seen the movie a grizzly man?
I love that.
That's a great movie. That was one of
my favorite unintentional comedies ever.
I swear to God.
I think Werner Herzog,
I would love to get drunk with
that guy and ask him, come on man.
You knew you were being funny movie.
No, I have not. I would love to though.
He's amazing.
He knows he's funny.
I had that question about him and I
watched a bad lieutenant. Did you,
have you seen this? No. He made a
remake of it with Nicholas Cage,
uh, three, four years ago. Got To
watch her. Why would they do that?
It's fantastic.
Nicholas Cage is off the fucking rock.
He's crazed in it.
It's really hard for me.
It's better. I'm a big Verner
hurt, shock Jesus. In your life.
I love Verna Hertz,
man.
Did you ever see him as a bad guy and
that shitty Tom Hanks movie or not Tom
Hanks,
Tom Cruise movie.
It was a Shitty Tom Cruise movie where
Tom Reach Jack reacher or something like
that. I never saw that.
Oh, I was at pizza shit.
We did a Tom cruise is like some
assassin or something like that.
Nobody can kill him. He kills everybody
and Werner Herzog is one of the bad guys.
Winds up killing Werner Herzog is such
a fucking clunky, stupid fucking movie,
but he has a nice car. It drives a
nice 1970 Chevelle. Beautiful car.
There is that. But Werner Herzog
is an actor in a rare moment,
but when he talks, all you can
think of, he's teammate Treadwell.
Timothy Treadwell in the
grizzly made pretty good. Yeah.
[inaudible] of nature.
If you seen the Antarctic did,
no, what does that, that's a great movie
and counters at the end of the world.
It's called. Oh, so Verna hertz talk, he's
like, he says at the beginning like, um,
you know,
some organization gave him $5 million
to make a movie about Antarctica.
And he said, and I, I said to them,
I will not make another movie
about the damn penguins.
So the deal was like, here's 5 billion or
whatever it was, just go do what you do.
Right. So he goes down there and he, uh,
first he's got this friend Henry Kaiser,
I think his name is,
used to be the Henry Kaiser
Band set ring a bell.
It's like in the late seventies, early
eighties, like a prog rock kind of band.
He quit music and became an underwater
photographer and now he's like the best
at, uh, under ice. Oh God.
Yeah. Imagining that, uh,
you've had vim Hoff on here. I'm going
to go to Amsterdam and cause he's,
I talked to his son and actually I was
texting with his son while you guys were
talking. Oh Wow. And uh, uh, his
son was like, yeah, we'll do it.
And I was like, but I don't want
to do a fucking Skype thing.
I want to meet with him. He's like,
I think he's an amazing human being.
So I go to Amsterdam a lot, so
sometime I'm going to go like, hang on.
His houseboat attitude radiates.
Really? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When he's sitting across,
he's got this fucking magnetic
energy. He's like, just a real deal.
Oh yeah, yeah. 26 world records.
I'd say when you get over 20 world
records, you're the real deal. Well,
and it's like my buddy who's rich from
wind farms, it's like when, I mean,
I don't know when,
but what I've seen him on your show and
I've seen the vice thing and it's not
about, look how cool I
am. It's not ego like, oh,
I gotta get another record
and prove, you know, whatever.
The dude's connected to
something really deep.
And the whole thing with
his wife and you know,
how it started is so like
beautiful and touching and sincere.
Yeah. You know, it's not an ego. Like I
saw that film a Everest the other day.
Have you seen that?
It's based on the Krakauer book and it's
been there a drama. Right? It's a drama.
Right. Well, but it's based on truth.
The true story of, of this, uh,
I don't know if it's 10 years ago,
there was a day when like 10 people died.
It was the most disastrous day on
Everest ever and all this shit.
But I was watching that and it's like,
okay,
you guys are all climbing Mount
Everest. Why? Who gives a fuck?
It's all ego, ego. Like it looks
really cool from the valley,
you know?
I mean it really does.
You don't need to like what is it
about you that you need to say?
I was at the top of Everest,
you know,
with my oxygen tanks and the five
Sherpas carrying all my shit, you know,
and I paid 60 grand to the guide
to like drag my sorry ass up there.
I just felt like, Eh, fuck that.
But then when you know, Eh,
that's a whole different thing.
It's not about ego.
Well he also did it in his fucking shorts
with no shirt and he said he was like,
to do it with clothes is too easy.
Like that's one of the things
he said it would really be easy.
There was a recent article,
I forget what publication,
but when some online thing where they
were talking about the business of going
to Everest,
that it's like this eco tourists
business now where you get all these rich
people and the higher the Sherpas
that do all the dirty work,
all the hard stuff carrying the oxygen,
carrying the food, carrying everything.
And all these people do is they sit in
their warm tents and they put on their
warm clothes and then they go where the
Sherpas tell them and they feel like
heroes. Yeah, but I used to do
a whole bit about Mount Everest,
that it's not like when you get to the
top of lucky charms guys waiting for you
with a bag of gold. Ah,
finally have reached the top.
Now you don't have work again for the rest
your life. Come with me. There's
free pussy and cocoa and attend.
Below is this bit about like the idea
of climbing to the top spot is like
impressive, but nobody gives a fuck if
you got to the lowest spot. Like nobody,
like I get to the lowest spot on
earth, bro. Like, what's it like?
You go down and then you go straight.
You get to the bottom. There's nowhere.
You can't go any further.
You're so brave.
Like no one cares about the lowest spot,
but everybody cares.
Mariana's trench a little while that's
dead. It was pretty good in the ocean.
Yeah. When you go in the ocean, that's
anytime work death valley or something.
Yeah.
That's just like there's some stupid
chimp thing about going to the top branch
is because like we associate the highest
branches with being safe from the
predators. Like that's the reason why
bedrooms have like if you have a house.
Yeah, the master bedroom is
almost always on the top floor.
And the reason is it's like you want
to be above to like look down at the
potential predators.
Like there's an association people
believe with chimps and trees and human
beings and having like houses
that are on the top war,
the master bedroom's on the top. That up.
Jamie, that sounds like bullshit to me.
It does sound like bullshit. Again,
this is something I read. I'm thinking,
uh,
the bedrooms being on top comes from
the centuries where people lived above
their domesticated animals and the heat
from the animals rose up and heated
their bedroom. What farts? Animal
Farm. Animal Heat. Body Heat. Really?
Yeah. Boy, that's an interesting theory.
But like Tibet, people live above their,
their ox. Yeah, that's
what I'm sure saying.
I would think it would be more
of a security thing though.
I'd like to live in a cave.
If you're above,
like people have to get to you and it's
way better strategically to be a time
you have a view. It's always
nice to have a view. That's nice.
You like to live in a cave. This is a k
for say on Bisbee, Arizona were ducks.
Dan Hopeless.
Maybe you don't buy it.
I had a house built into a cave to
go to a busy bee and check that out.
I want to go before Doug dies. I don't
know how much longer he's got left.
He's hoping he's going to hang in there
for a long time. But you're right. I mean,
I know he's a bit of a wild man.
Probably live forever.
He'll do a Keith Richards pissing on
Migraine, but he, uh, he has hernia.
It's like he can lie on his back and
flex the stomach and like is bulges like
his bulges in his stomach where
they pop out in several places.
Like his internal organs are like
trying to escape from his body cavity.
It's got to get that shit sewn up. No,
he won't do it. It's not going to happen.
We'll take care of that shit
with Budweiser and cigarettes.
A little duct tape mocks
me, mocks me, and he goes,
how many surgeries have you had? Rogan
and Lincoln had a fuck load. None.
That's like his bear. A barometer
for like, who's healthier?
Who's living a healthier life? I've
been fucking stitch back together again.
Six or seven times. None. I resonate
with that sometimes. You know,
I see somebody getting hurt some and
I'm like, yeah, didn't happen to me.
Look at me. I'm sitting here
saying, buy a surfboard. It didn't.
And then a gun. What did
you like? Laird Hamilton,
the out there every day looking sleek.
Call six Paki and shit flexing
as your fucking ride. The wave.
I don't know what it
would do for me though.
Well you read that thing that I
wrote for Esquire. I do the, um,
the idea of you're,
you're the human body's ultimately a
lot like a sand castle and that, yeah.
And that's really at the end of the day,
I mean enjoy it while you've got it,
but at the end of the day, it's pretty
much pointless. I mean, we really are,
you know, Kubler Ross's five
stages of grief, right? The,
you know what I'm talking about?
I've heard that expression,
but I don't know what they are.
It's good to memorize cause you see them
everywhere that the acronym is Dab de
da De da. So it's denial. So this is
whether you're like losing your job,
your marriage,
you,
someone close to you dying or you just
got like the pancreatic cancer diagnosis,
right?
It's all the same.
And you and some people skip stages and
never get to the lower ones, whatever.
But the sequence is denial,
anger, so denial like, oh no,
there's a mistake. This can't be right.
Right. Then there's anger. Like why me?
That's not fair. I don't smoke. And
uh, and then there's bargaining. Okay,
I look from now on,
I'm going to work out right from now on,
I'm going to eat right,
I'm going to,
and then there's a depression
and then there's acceptance.
Acceptance is if you're lucky enough and
evolved enough and psychedelics I think
really help get to the acceptance stage.
That's why they're so a psilocybin,
so effective with end of life, uh,
treatment for anxiety.
People are facing the end.
They take a silicide been dose and
have an experience in there. Like, Oh,
I'm not afraid of dying anymore.
It's supposed to be one of the most
amazing things for people on that. Yeah.
It helps them accept this idea.
I remember Larry Hagman was talking about
that in this interview that he did on
CNN of all places. And uh, they were
interviewing him about, you know, like,
like times in his life and you know,
what, what, what like impactful moments.
And he said, well, the
last time I took Lsd,
and you could tell like the
person who was interviewing him,
who was interviewing him, it
didn't expect that. And he said,
bullied it alleviated my fear of dying.
I really, I no longer worry about death,
you know?
And he said the experience,
whatever he had when he was on Lsd
was so profound that it's sort of like
relaxed into, and he had
that air about him too. Like,
like a guy who was just there. He's
there, he's not like putting on a show.
He's not like faking it and he's
not, he's just there. He's, he's him,
you know.
And he lived at like a fairly sustainable
life for a wealthy famous guy.
Had He, I think, I believe his
house was completely off the grid.
I had some house in the
Santa Monica Mountains. Yeah,
I remember reading something about that.
And I wonder if his house
was still available.
I'd look to fucking by Larry Hagman's
house. Pretty Dope. Better than a cave?
Probably, yes. Maybe not though.
Cave would probably like be really
efficient as far as like keeping you cool
temperature, same all year
round. You know, it's,
you can have like grass growing
on the roof. That's pretty dirty.
Fucking hobbit house.
Remember they had those big brown doors,
the side of the Shyer, well you
know this thing about fear of death,
you were talking earlier about um,
making sex,
like restricting access and then using it
as a lure to get people to work, right?
Yeah. So in, in civilized to death, the
last chapter that have just written,
by the way, I'm fucking done while I'm
in the rewrites now. But like, yeah,
you hit the end of the book. So now it's
just about editing and rewrites and,
but you know how they say like work
expands to fill the space allotted to it.
Well, I've been in the U S for
like four years off and on. Right.
And like I finally decided like, no,
we're going back to Spain end of December.
So the book gets done in
November. Of course, of course,
because you had a deadline.
A lot of people say that
with a lot of things they do,
like they like deadlines because deadlines
or force you to fucking just cram
that work in and, and it eliminates
any possibility of excuses.
If you have a deadline, I just
blow by deadlines. Do you? Yeah,
it's gotta be structural in my life.
If it's someone telling me, Chris,
it's gotta be done by Tuesday. I'm
like, yeah, whatever. That's negotiable,
but I feel like I'm moving to
Spain and December. All right,
and then you finish it in time because I
got no kids. I got no mortgage. I mean,
I do, but it's nothing and it's
like, well, I don't really, yeah.
I had this conversation with a friend
of mine and obviously, you know,
I have kids and I love having kids. I love
my family. I'm very, very, very happy.
Couldn't,
wouldn't want it any other way,
but I have this conversation with
my friend who also has a family.
It also has kids, and we were
talking about this guy we know,
I want to say his name. He's a
successful guy, he's wealthy,
he's doing really well. He's a well loved
guy, but he doesn't have any children,
and he goes, fucking sad. I
go, why is he sad? And he goes,
she doesn't have any kids sad.
He goes, what's it all for? I go,
what's yours off for? I
go, you're going to have,
you're going to give it to your
kids and they're going to die too.
Fuck difference. Does
it make I go, I don't,
I used to resent that when
I didn't have children.
I always resented this
idea that a meaningful life
only involves reproduction.
I resent it today and I love my kids.
I resent it. I think that's nonsense.
I think you could have a beautiful,
meaningful life and never reproduce.
You don't need to reproduce.
How do you affect the people around you?
How do you feel?
My family,
it's not just my family of the
children I've made and my wife,
my family is my friends. The people I
love. Those are my family. You know,
like a family, like put it,
put whatever word you know,
call it whatever noise you
want to make with your face.
But what's important to me is who you
love and who you take in and who you
surround yourself with.
I have this group of amazing,
beautiful people I share time
with and whether they were born out of
my wife's pussy or whether they were born
out of someone else's pussy,
who cares like that.
This idea that it's only meaningful if
you surround yourself with people that
came out of, you know, your
own Dna I think is it's so,
it's not just shortsighted,
it's dangerously egotistical.
I think it's just,
it's bad for you.
It's bad for everybody.
I think it's, it's an avoidance of death.
Yeah. And that's what I was gonna say,
like you were talking about sex.
What I argue in the end of this book is
that there's also a mechanism built the
same sort of mechanism built around
death. That we're terrified. We're the,
we're the only animal that knows
it dies, right? Homo Sapiens,
sapiens, the homeowner who
knows it knows what do we know?
We know we're going to die.
So what did we do then?
We develop all these mechanisms,
some conscious,
some not for avoiding thinking about that.
And I think civilization is one of them.
We align ourselves with something
bigger than ourselves. So, you know,
and there's all this really interesting
research on terror management theory.
It's called, where they look at
the subconscious mechanisms. Uh,
when people are reminded of mortality,
they react differently to
people outside their group.
They're much more aggressive and
much more aligned with the, you know,
the identity of their group and all that.
Um, but so that, that's what I'm arguing.
And I think the reason, think
about psychedelics, right?
And you've heard this a million times.
Every culture that's had access to them,
he's seen them as the greatest
gifts of the gods, the greatest,
most sacred things that
we have in America.
You get busted with a bag
of mushrooms at a concert.
You go to prison longer than if you
kill somebody. Think about that.
What does that mean? What the
fuck are we? So afraid you have
a Duffel bag filled with mushrooms
and you're selling them at a concert.
It is literally possible that you
will have a larger prison sentence.
And if you accidentally kill
someone in a street fight,
minimum mandatory sentencing,
right?
Second degree murder versus distribution
schedule one psychedelics. Yeah.
I know a guy who's doing anything
here a year for manslaughter a year,
he's doing a year. He shot someone in
a road rage incident a year, a year.
And if he had mushrooms in his
car, it'd be 10 years. Yeah.
It's very possible if you're in the wrong
place, the wrong part of the country,
the wrong judge.
And what do mushrooms do?
They give you peace or they
freak out depending on how, how,
how hard you're holding on to it.
You hold it on those bad trips.
I've never had a bad trip on mushrooms,
but I understand where they come from.
I've had bad trips on weed.
I've had those woo over eating to a tree.
That's especially early in my career as a,
a,
a psycho, not a, yeah, I had some fucking,
because like we're were talking about
before they make sprays now ladies and
gentlemen, I just want to be honest. Uh,
I'm not entirely sober right now, uh,
for the show or a little
spray under my tongue and um,
they make stuff that's too fucking strong.
Like Joey Diaz,
who's the savage of all savages.
What he does is he'll take
a 500 milligram THC candy,
which um, you know what I like? I like 20.
I like the 20 twenty's a good dose. Like
before I go on stage, I like our 20.
It's not strong, it's light.
It's a little fun with happy.
He'll take off fucking 500 and then he
takes a rapper for a cheaper lower dose
and he puts the 500 in the lower dose
rapper and he gives them to people.
Uh,
see that's not cool
to him at school. He loves it. He loves
dosing people. I'm very against that.
I mean I spent a lot of
time around psychedelics and
that's the one thing that I
could never forgive. If you ever
heard a Dunkin story about Joey,
Joey gave Dunkin some fucking cookie
of death and it was just unbelievably
powerful. And he told Dunkin, look,
you know, just see it. Just, you know,
how strong is it? It's not that
bad. Just eat it. So Dunkin eats it.
An hour later he is at his home
in a fucking tornado of terror,
just spiraling, freaking out. And then
he gets a phone call and it's Joey Diaz.
He goes,
welcome to my world.
I guess. I guess if it's coming from
Joey Diaz, you should know better.
That's the guy though.
I mean that's just Joey's,
that's what you get when you do it
with Joey. I'd love that guy. I'm so,
I'm so happy. I know him. So
happy he exists. I've had one bad,
bad. I mean, I've had crazy
shit happen. You know,
like I probably have told you the story
about when I got stung by a Scorpion
when I was tripping. Oh yeah.
So I mean I've had, and I
thought I was going to die.
Right. But that ended up being
a really good experience.
But the last time I did acid,
I did a heroic dose. Don't,
don't, don't, don't. Yeah.
And it ended,
I won't go through the whole story,
but it ended with me wandering onto the
grounds of a psychiatric hospital and
hiding the metal filings.
And I heard all these weird voices and
I hid under this Rhododendron Bush.
And it turns out that they were the
patients taking a walk and they were like
wandering the grounds and I'm like,
cowering under this Rhododendron Bush.
Like having cried and lost my shirt
and you know, I was just a fucking
tired and my face.
Thank God
I can lock you up. Yeah. It's
crazy. Bastard. Or I'm a doctor.
My name is Chris Ryan. I want to wrote a
book about sex. No, not that Chris Ryan,
the other groups. Ryan Nolan.
Ryan the picture. Oh my God.
You know about that research where
they, uh, I think it was at Yale,
um,
in
a psychiatry residents.
The teacher said, okay,
the project is this weekend,
you have to go out.
There were like six or seven students
had to go out and check themselves into a
psychiatric hospital. Ooh. Um,
separate different ones. Right.
Saying that they were hearing voices that
we're telling them to hurt themselves,
check in and then spend the night and
then the next day explaining the situation
and come back.
And none of them could get out because
they wouldn't believe cause they're like,
no, listen, I'm a medical student. I go
to Yale, my professor, this was a project?
No, not one of them could get out.
Wow. So how did they get them out?
Because the professor went,
oh,
because the professor knew that
was going to happen. Right. Wow.
Cause he's like he,
it was to show like how helpless
psychiatric patients are.
Cause even when they're telling you
the truth, you don't believe him.
Well he's not always the case. Like when
everyone's being accused of anything,
you feel guilty even if you're not like
I've been pulled over before and been
stone cold sober.
And especially before I was famous
and worried that I'm not sober,
that I did something wrong with the
cops. Like what did I do? What did I do?
You start going through your Rolodex
of Shit that you might've done but he
didn't do anything. And that's where
ended to false confessions a lot of times.
Well listen,
if you put enough pressure on people,
especially if you lock them up and like
this is what the fuck is going on with
Guantanamo Bay,
they just released this guy that just was
in there for 14 years and have a story
about it and then being beaten
and he was fucking innocent.
He didn't do anything. They had no
charges. There was no, there's no,
no reason to detain him to suspicion and
suspicion is a very weird thing cause
if I suspect you, what do you plot and
Chris Ryan, you come on my podcast,
but I think you've got to fucking
and alternative intention.
There's something going on behind
your eyes. I see it out. I figure,
oh you're here for my fucking free coffee.
You know like when people start
like accusing you of things,
you start wondering about
your own intentions.
You start like we exist in some sort of
a strange state where we're constantly
in seeking approval.
We seek approval from each other and we,
we like to live in at least some
somewhat of a state of harmony with our
neighbors and our friends
and our community.
And when someone is pointing to you at
being a disruptor of harmony in some way,
shape, or form, you know, like if
you're in a relationship, I've,
I've had friends that had
been in relationships like,
man, my fucking girlfriend,
she's always accusing me of doing
this and accusing me of doing that.
And I'm like, you got to get break
up with her because that, that'll,
that'll you'll get sucked into that world.
Yeah.
You will get sucked into her world of
anxiety and craziness and you'll become
something different than you are now.
You'll become what she's
accusing you of being.
If you don't become that you at the
very least be a mess because you're
constantly defending yourself. Like, I'm
just going to deal with it. I'll go home,
I'll talk to her. Like, this is the, the,
that is the embodiment. That is the
definition of a codependent relationship.
Right? Like you're, you're allowing
her to be this accusatory person or he,
you know, allow a golden woman
with a man. Same thing. It hasn't,
it's not sex dependent
or gender dependent,
but it's this weird thing that happens
to people when someone starts pointing at
you and saying, you know
what, Chris, you're just a
fucking asshole. You know you,
you just, you don't care about anybody
but yourself. And you're like, do I?
God Damn it, you start. We'll have
to look at yourself and go, is this,
is this true? And if someone says it
enough, you'll start to think it's true.
You start to believe it.
So if you get a guy and you lock them
up in some fucking cage and everyday you
tell him that he's a criminal and you ever
day, you tell them you're a terrorist,
you're plotting with Isis here.
Ah,
you fucking put an orange
jumpsuit in them and,
and then he does want to kill you.
Then before you know it,
they're fucking memory is so distorted
and twisted by years of beatings and
you're feeding them dog food and
kicking them in the deck. Oh,
who is that guy anymore? 14 years in
Guantanamo Bay and they let them go.
I would be amazed if he doesn't become a
terrorist now. Yeah. It would be amazing.
No better breeding ground for terrorists
than a terrorist in prison or criminal
camp. Yeah. Then prison, look at our
criminal justice system. It's a Mac.
It's not about helping anyone.
It's not about reducing crime.
It's just responding to some
primordial revenge fantasy,
which we know perfectly
doesn't work, especially for
shit like nonviolent crimes,
which is a giant percentage
of our prisons. Yeah.
I mean that is like one of the sickest
aspects of our culture that we have more
people in prison.
Then all the countries in the world,
there's no one in any other
country including military
police states. Yeah. Yeah.
It's crazy. It's, it's fucking, it's the
land of the free, right home of the brave.
That's right.
Yeah,
and you're going to go to France and
sitting in the Back Bay and France and
Spain. Same Shit. Oh, it's on the fourth
or you're talking about me personally.
Well, you are going to escape.
I beautiful country here.
I'm going to Columbia first though.
I think I'm going to go
hang on my friend's yacht
in the Caribbean for awhile,
so hang with that dude.
CFLA stay taller if I were
really ballsy cause he's,
he's doing Christmas with
his family elsewhere and I
know that Yod is sitting in
the British Virgin Islands empty right
now with the crew. But just your luck,
you'll get on it by herself
and that's when the pirates,
we'll call him planning on
kidnapping. I'll defend it, you know,
and like I'm Chris Ryan, I'm an
author. I'm not a billionaire. Exactly.
We saw your Ted talk be
dead is only funded itch.
It's good.
Yeah.
Fucking yachts are weird in that sense
in that if you have one Mike man,
it's beautiful and it's amazing,
but people look at that floating
fucking thing and it's a bank.
It's like a floating bank inside of it.
There's money.
You just got to figure
out how to extract it.
And if you can grab one of those people
that's inside of it and take them and
whisk them away and then contact
the other people and say, hey,
you got to give me some of
that money. If you want one
of these people back. But
on the other hand, a yacht,
this big e,
if you take someone off that yacht,
you're going to have some serious
guys come and look. And for you,
it's not like a couple of old
people on a sailboat. Yeah.
But if you're in like Mexico,
they can't find El Chapo.
If you can't get to El Chapo,
I ain't going to hear you buy that
shit about El Chapo and the tunnel.
I don't buy that.
What do you mean by it?
I don't believe he escaped
through the tunnel. Why is that?
Because you don't look,
he's world famous for being the
dude who builds tunnels. Okay,
well before they caught him, I didn't
know he was famous for being a dude.
Oh yeah.
He's the dude who has all these tunnels
under the border with the train tracks
and all that. That's how he's like
this major smuggler. Right? Right.
So he's the tunnel dude.
And he's got all these teams of engineers
who are great at building tunnels,
and they're always finding them
in San Diego on all this. Right.
So you finally catch the dude after he's
already escaped right from the other
one five years ago or whatever that was.
She finally catch the dude again.
You put them in the most
secure prison in Mexico,
number one,
supermax Mexican prison and dude's are
building a tunnel with power tools into
the prison and you don't hear it and
don't expect it and don't think about it.
And they're like at some
fucking construction site,
a mile outside of the wall of the prison.
Then you're not checking that bull shit.
Give me a fucking break.
This guy paid off the prison guards.
That's why they're all arrested now.
Paid off the,
the head of the prison paid
off the senators and the
governors and the probably
the president and then they
built the tunnel to make,
give a viable story for the dip shits
to like us to listen to and say, Oh,
you skated through the Tono.
No,
he didn't any walked out the fucking
front door and got into a limo.
Gimme a break, but they need the tunnel.
He definitely got out to the tunnel.
There's video of it. There's
security video. But I agree with you.
Who would then all the other ones who
gave us the security video of him going
behind that little wall and
crouching down and disappearing.
Who gave us that video here to get
them through? Through the autonomy.
The tunnel exists. It exists as
a story. Oh, that's so strange.
You're a conspiracy theorist.
That's the dumbest conspiracy ever.
The actually told exists, but it doesn't
mean he, he used it. That means it exists,
so that will say, oh, you got out
through the tunnel of what age?
We won't look at all
the people he paid off.
I feel like I'm talking to Eddie
Bravo. This is, this is crazy.
Of course these deep paid off some people,
but I think you paid off some people
to allow him to build a tunnel.
I think that's the outcomes razor
point of view. Yeah, I don't think so.
I think the outcomes raise their point
of view is with the amount of corruption
that we know exists in the Mexican
government that he paid people off.
The guy's got billions of dollars.
You paid people off. They said, okay,
but we got to like come
up with some cover story.
We can't just let you walk out the front
door because then it's obvious that you
paid us off because there's
no other explanation.
So we make up this story of how we'll
okay have build a tunnel that'll take
a couple of months. It's
fine. They build the tunnel.
We say you went out through the tunnel
will leave this fucking evidence and
whatever, the little motor bike and all
this bullshit. And that's the story.
That's the way they do this
shit. Well, the tunnel,
it was a mile long and they say it took
a year. They say it took a year to build.
Yeah, but because it had,
it had electricity in it.
Yeah. It had ventilation.
It had an electric bike.
Like he hopped on electric bike and
shot down to the end of that thing.
You don't buy it. I
don't put it in Mexico.
He's just fucking paint people off.
It's the way it works.
This securest building in Mexico that
is like saying the prettiest gorilla,
you know, the security, the
most secure prison in Mexico.
Mexican prisons are pretty cool actually.
If you're going to go to prison,
Mexico is a good place. If you have a
little money. Oh, if you have bunny,
if you have a little money you
don't need a lot. But like uh,
cause in Mexican prisons,
you know like your wife can
come visit and stay with you.
You can have like good food. People can
bring you food, you can get cigarettes,
you can watch TV.
It's not like American where like you're
going to be in a sterile environment.
In Mexico there's a lot of their poorest,
there's a lot of stuff you have to
stay there, but your wife can come,
your girlfriend can come, hookers
can come. Hookers. Real wow. Yeah.
Wasn't that like one of the things that
they had been upset about him and the
previous incarceration that he had
been bringing in prostitutes? Yeah.
He had like ran the prison. Yeah, but
he got out of that one too. Right.
And how do you get out of
that one? I'm like, whoa.
He said he like went
out through the laundry.
I think it was like in a laundry thing.
Well, there was a story recently,
we were actually talking about this in
a previous podcast that they had come
very close to catching him, uh, like
within the last couple of weeks.
And then he broke his leg jumping
out a window or something. Yeah.
They said he believes he broke his leg.
Yeah.
He was wished away by a security
guards. El Chapo, who knows?
This is terrifying that this gigantic
organized crime empire is built out of the
drug war because of
prohibition. They've, I mean,
it's no different than Al Capone during
the alcohol prohibition that we had.
Yeah. That's really good.
That's, it's really interesting,
right? Yeah. Well it's,
it's the same mechanism we've been
talking about all afternoons crashing.
You repress it,
the pressure,
but it's like a steam engine or a
internal combustion engine, you know,
create pressure,
no release.
And then use the energy of the
release for your own purposes. Yeah.
Just finds a way out.
Right.
If finds a little valve like my
poor girl with her shave vagina,
the girl from high school,
crazy girl,
the poor repress girl down curl was also,
this is the first girl that I ever met
that told me that she liked it when her
boyfriend hit her. Yeah. That was real,
cause we work together too. And uh,
we were working together and she
was crying to me that, you know,
this guy that this guy that she was dating
beat or the same guy shaved her pussy.
He went whole hog.
It's crazy dude.
But that he had a hit her and uh,
and she's like,
you know what's fucked up though?
I like it. And I was like, whoa.
Like I remember thinking like, I don't
even know where to begin with this. I go,
you like it? She goes, I'm part of
it. I don't know what the fuck is.
It just turns me on.
Yeah. Well that, I mean, that relates
to what we were saying earlier.
Like we don't choose what we want.
We don't choose what feels good.
Things feel good. I mean there's a,
I mean this is really a fucked up
thing to talk about, but it's real. Um,
one of the reasons that
rape is so psychologically
damaging to women is a lot of
women come when they're being raped.
Yeah.
So there that imagine the schism that
that creates in your own experience where
you're like,
one part of you is saying this is the
worst fucking violation that's ever
happened in this guy has, you know,
is a monster and your body's coming.
Yeah. Like what the fuck? And I, and see,
I think that's similar to what we were
talking about with these little boys who
are having experiences that gets sealed
as a pleasurable experience in one way.
Even though later they look back on it
and say that was a violation and a crime.
So wild.
He's such a very,
very strange thing because it's
not just about reproducing,
it's there's psychological aspects to it.
There's sociological aspects to it.
There's forbidden things that
become more appealing because of it.
It's so strange. What, what,
what exists with human beings and that
it doesn't exist at all in any of the
animal world.
This idea of being conscious and being
aware and if also contemplating all the
variables and at this sort of combines
together with the biological needs of
reproduction and it
creates this really potent,
confusing cocktail of ideas that gets,
I mean that's one of the reasons
why it's so offensive when you,
you find out that someone that you know,
uh,
has either been raped or someone that
you know has been accused of raping
someone and they didn't do it or that
someone that you know has been involved
somehow in a rape,
like they were a part of a rape or
they maybe were in a gang bang rape or
something like that. It's just like, Whoa,
my whole world's been thrown upside down.
Like this idea of what people can and
can't do to each other. It's so crazy.
It's human beings like forcing themselves
on other human beings is so strange.
And then when you hear how many women
have rape fantasy, well you like, well,
well fuck Jesus Christ. That's
what you want. No, no, no,
no, no, no. It's what I enjoy thinking
about. Well what the fuck does that mean?
Do you want to get raped or no, no, no,
definitely not. But I fantasize about it.
It makes me calm. What? Yeah, what
are you saying? Like my buddy was, uh,
having sex with his
girlfriend once and uh,
she admitted while they're having sex
that what she really wants is a bunch of
black guys to come over and just fuck
the shit out of her against her will hold
her down and he and he, he'd never
thought about it the same way again.
It was like he was fucked.
Like the relationship was done.
It was like he couldn't handle it.
Yeah. Like she just wanted big,
muscular black guys to come over, just
fuck the shit out of it. Him just hold it,
shut up bitch and just, Oh, just, and
she didn't really want it to happen,
but she wanted it to happen like in her
head, that was the fantasy, the fantasy.
Like when she would be alone,
no one's there and she would lock
her bedroom door and masturbate.
She would be thinking about getting raped.
I can some crazy way like that.
She wanted that.
She didn't want a
relationship with that guy.
She didn't want that guy to nuzzle her
take care of her and cuddle and watch
Netflix.
No,
she wanted that guys come in her body
to make some like super potent a child
birthed out of violence.
Hey animal passion man as fuck though.
Right.
That's the last remnants of that.
Yeah.
Well I don't know the last five minutes
but I mean, you know the UFC fighting.
What's that? You know that's animal
passion. That's animal like basic.
I mean I know there's art to it and you
know the way you look at it's different
than the way I look at it.
But I look at it and I see two dudes
like unleashing the inner beast.
It's hard to argue,
you know,
all the arguments to women and
you know in the case of the women.
But what about these cases you read
about every once in a while where like,
like a dude goes to a woman's house at
night and she thinks it's her husband and
they have sex and then she finds out
it was just some guy. What? Yeah,
every couple of years you read one of
these cases where like some guys like he
just walks into a house and had sex with
a woman and she's, and then she's like,
wait a minute, you're not my husband.
Those things seem unbelievable to me,
but I've seen them several times.
Well,
weird things can happen,
especially if you're in a situation
where like maybe your neighbor has been
thinking about fucking your wife forever
or the post man. And they're like,
maybe they know your schedule. He
doesn't come home until nine every night.
He works this shift and you know,
and I can just get in there on Tuesdays
because that's when he's not there for
that deck. I know twins who did that.
Really? Yeah. Oh, that seems more likely.
But he's also a problem
with sleeping pills, man. Oh
yeah. The ambien fucking you.
Yeah. That's fucking very, very
dangerous. I've had a bunch of friends,
have some really bizarre experiences.
Like one of my buddies woke up in the
car driving somewhere and realize what he
was doing.
He had already gotten in the car and was
already driving and it was on some sort
of weird autopilot when he realized
that he was driving somewhere. Yeah,
that's heavy. It's very scary
because someone can do things to you,
I'm sure while you're under the
influence of sleeping pills and you would
probably just accept it or think it
was a part of your dream or you know,
or what.
But when you're taking something
that forces you into that state were,
were monkeying with the mind,
that sort of sort of strange way.
And these companies that make these pills
will have you believe that it's safe
and easy.
It's cause you die.
So if you don't die the
label it is safe. Look, he,
we woke him up or he woke up in the
morning and we checked his heart rate.
Everything's fine. His blood
plates. And how do you feel,
Chris? I feel great. Well,
I had a wonderful night sleep and in the
safe it's safe but it's not necessarily
safe.
I mean whether it's safe,
there's possible potential repercussions
for doing that shit and one of them is
that something happens to
you while you're doing it.
I think El Chapo was on Ambien.
You think so? That's what happened.
Maybe aliens abducted him.
Look this, this is how, how fucking easy
it is to come in here and talk to you.
All right. I came in thinking, I
dunno what we're going to talk about.
We just talked a month ago.
I don't have anything new to talk about
so I made a couple of notes. I haven't,
I haven't gotten either one of them.
We always have shit to talk about it.
You really worried about
that? Well, I feel bad.
I mean if it's just you and me
hanging out and Jamie, that's fine,
but if there are a million people
listening in there like that,
that asshole was just on
there a few weeks ago.
I don't want to hear his shit again.
Don't worry about those people.
Can't think about that there. Those
people are really nice. Actually.
Most of them are nice and looked at asked
majority. Yeah. I mean like, you know,
everyone talks about how the Internet
brings out the asshole and everybody.
Right. But like the, the
people who, you know,
go to the trouble of rating my
podcast or putting comments,
they're fucking beautiful. Like if I'm
feeling down I go read them. Like, Oh,
do you guys love me? It's beautiful. Well
you're giving them something for free.
That's awesome sometimes, but
it's a cool exchange, you know.
Yeah. I actually, I think I might've
mentioned the last time I was on that,
you know, you and Duncan
had sort of, you know,
when we get together and talk about
the future, I'm like the Dutch,
what I'm going to die. But, uh,
I read this book called future
perfect by Steven Johnson and uh,
I got a bunch of books that
I was going to trash, right?
Like there's the rational optimist by
Matt Ridley and there are a couple of
books that are all like, oh,
everything's great. And I was like, okay,
I'll respond to these arguments.
Cause,
obviously I'm making a different
argument so I should acknowledge them.
So I trashed Matt Ridley,
I trash Steven Pinker,
I trashed from other people and
then I read this a future. Perfect.
And it's like fuck this guy's right. He's
right. He's makes really good arguments.
And they're very much along the lines of
what you were saying about the power of
unfiltered media that's happening,
that's unleashed by the Internet,
creating these emergent,
uh,
peer networks that never
could have existed before.
So good ideas can spread really quickly
and get capital really quickly if it's
a, you know, business sort of, or
money distribution kind of thing.
And therefore, uh, things can change.
Like I'm thinking,
I'm looking back at every civilization
that's ever existed and they fail, fail.
They all collapsed and they
all follow the same patterns,
but there wasn't this
sort of immediate world,
global mind. And now there is.
And as I said earlier, you know,
Homo Sapiens sapiens that harmony
that knows it knows what does it know.
It knows it's going to die.
The first thing that consciousness becomes
aware of is its own mortality. Right.
So what I'm hoping is that when this
global mind clicks on as I think it's
happening right now,
that's when we become aware of our
mortality as a species and as a planet.
And maybe there's some like radical
transformative power in that and we'll all
end up living like Joe
Rogan in a hundred years.
Definitely thing there's a radical
transform formative power of the instant
exchanging of ideas and information
because the, the good ideas,
they get vetted out, like everybody's
ideas get discussed and bandied about.
And even, you know, podcasts, ideas,
like there's some ideas that people, uh,
you know, throw out on podcasts and
they get debated and everybody gets,
there's so much intensity and so much,
you know,
discussion and debate about
who's right and who's wrong.
And it's because I think one
of the reasons why people
have so much of a vested
interest in these things is they recognize
the significance of exposing ideas
for what they truly are and trying to
figure out which ones are good and which
ones are bad.
And also the repercussions of living in
a world filled with bad ideas and bad
assumptions that we're all acting on.
And we've all,
whether it's racism or homophobia or the
fucking Federal Reserve or the fucking
two party system,
these things,
all these things we know by virtue of
like examining all the facts like, God,
this is not the best way to do this,
but this is the system
that we're stuck with.
So when we're making communities and
even if they're open ended online
communities of people exchanging ideas,
there's still kind of communities like
people I talk with on Twitter are people,
uh, that I, I read their
Facebook posts or this is a,
there is a community to that because
we are exchanging information.
We all communicating with each other,
right?
And there's a community that comes
with podcasts as well. I mean,
the people that are
listening to this right now,
the millions of people that will
get ahold of this conversation,
they're a part of a community.
And whether or not they agree
or disagree or hate or love,
there's still in somehow or another,
there's still in some way communing
with each other. We're, we're,
we're talking and communicating and
everybody has this ability now to exchange
ideas and the good ones sort of resonate.
And because of that,
I think we can exchange
ideas and evolve ideas and,
and evolve our own perceptions
of things in a much, much,
much quicker way than ever before and
ever in the history of the human race.
Quick.
One of the reasons why I'm so optimistic.
Yeah. And I agree with you and
that's what this book really,
he really gets into that and
examples of it, what's it called?
It's called future perfect.
And the author is Steven Johnson.
And like he talks about
Kickstarter and how, you know,
Kickstarter two years
after it was launched,
it was already funding more art than
the National Endowment for the arts.
Wow. You know, in two years.
And uh, I mean, I, you know,
you're talking about how things
resonate and, and they happen quicker.
And I think another aspect
of it is that until now,
the ideas that became powerful
had to have market appeal.
You had to be able to make
money from it somehow.
Whereas now like here you are
here, we push this button, this,
I mean it costs nothing to produce
these things, these podcasts, right?
They go out. If the idea is good,
a million people hear about it,
that resonates further.
It doesn't matter if it's a sellable idea,
it just matters if it's a good idea.
Whereas before,
when all the media was controlled by
companies that needed to be making money
somehow, right? It had to
have that commercial appeal.
A lot
of times people wouldn't even venture
into something like this unless they
thought that it was profitable.
Right. You know, when I got into this,
I did it entirely just for fun.
I think it's one of the reasons why
it's been successful is that I had no,
no ulterior motive at all.
Like it was just fun.
I just saw a lot of fun we'd be doing and
we started doing these a long time ago.
Um,
uh,
a platform called Justin TV we were doing
from the group member who would stream
from a laptop card.
I used to have this,
a Verizon card is ticking my laptop,
which stream from green rooms in between
shows and it would just be us fucking
around and talking to the camera and
maybe we'd add answered questions or
something like that. If there was a chat
and there was never a thought like, hey,
this is going to be
really profitable someday.
So let's make sure that our guests are
only like really acceptable mainstream
guests that we know we're going to get a
lot of attention and sometimes I'll get
complaints about that.
Like how come you keep having your friends
or some hunter dude or some comedian
or a fighter that I don't know.
How come you can't run and how come you
can't get Obama black? Marion got Obama,
you know,
how can you,
how come you don't get Steven Spielberg
won't look fat fucking I'm not even
trying. How about that? I just
want to have conversations.
If I really wanted to have
a conversation with Obama,
I don't know even know if it is possible
because I think if the fucking secret
service, listen to any of the shit that
I've said before, they'd probably, yeah,
I'd probably be removed from
the discussion. But I mean,
I feel like there's some people that I
probably could talk to that I'm not drawn
to that I'm not drawn to them.
I'm not, I'm not interested in it,
but if I am interested in them,
I'll pursue them.
Like there's some famous
people that I find fascinating.
I would love to talk to them. Verna
Hertz, thug dude. Yeah, I would,
but not just because they're famous.
No, but if you have a talk show,
like if you have the tonight show
or something along those lines,
you can't do a show like that unless
you have famous people on that.
That's the whole model. Right?
That's, that's the only way to do it.
And it's someone pitching something.
Right, exactly. It's going to be,
don't get to choose.
That's the other problem.
If you're the host of one of those shows
and you're a part of some multimedia
conglomerate like NBC or universal
or whatever the fuck it is,
they're going to bring all these
people, this is Mike, blah blah blah.
He's got this fucking fast and
furious 47 coming out and you know,
and you've got to have that guy.
What was it like on the set working with
Michelle Rodriguez? Oh man, she's crazy.
First of all, we're just like a
tight knit family. We would go in.
This film is amazing and I got a real
big thanks out to Steven Spielberg for
produce all that bullshit. It's this
through. It was great. It's nonsense,
it's nonsense and that's all
you're ever going to get.
And these little seven minute
sound bites in between commercials.
You do the seven minutes,
we'll be right back. All right.
And then you go to commercial
and then fucking tie. Toyota Woo.
Bababa Abilify or do you feel depressed?
And then next thing you know, Bam,
new guest and their new top 40 song.
I love apples and the fucking sing
their stupid song and then a, all right,
thanks for coming. We'll be back next week
with Tom Cruise. We got Oprah Winfrey,
you know,
it's like the flaws,
the flaws signs Kim Kardashian
and you know you're going to watch
these famous heads say non thing,
say nonsense.
And that's all those shows are.
And that's one of the reasons why those
shows are they're they, they, they,
they're an old,
it's an old model.
And I think that model is not
going to work in this new world,
this new world of computers
and the Internet and phones
and this new world wants
real information.
They want to know who the fuck are you.
You don't like you or don't like you.
You're you.
And Chris Ryan is Chris Ryan. Every
time I've seen you talk, you're you.
And that's what people like
and that's what resonates.
They know whether or not they agree
with you or disagree with you.
They know where you're coming from
as a place of honest consideration.
And I tried to do that as well.
Everything I tried to do, I try,
whether I'm right or I'm wrong,
if I get it wrong or I'm
clunky or I'm coming,
I'm not trying to be anything
other than who I am. You know?
And I think we're all in this together
and we're all learning and evolving and
growing and expanding our ideas together.
And I think one of the beautiful things
about podcasts is that you get to share
this with other people.
And there's a lot of people right now,
and it might be listening to this and a
truck on the way to somewhere and they
got fucking three hours to go and there
and they're thinking about shedding.
It's enriching their ideas and their
expanding their own ideas because of it.
And maybe they're adding something
in their head. They're thinking,
you know why these guys are right, but
you know what else? What about this?
And then they have their
own idea from that.
And maybe that could become a fucking
business opportunity for them or a book
that they write or they
start their own podcast.
I've gotten fucking hundreds and hundreds
of messages from people that said they
started their own podcasts from listening
to this and that alone, who knows,
you could nail some fucking podcast and
that podcast might be the best thing
that anybody's ever heard before and
it might all come out of you hearing
tangentially speaking or the Duncan
Trussell family hour or whatever.
And I think in that sense,
like everybody has a voice now,
you know, in some really unique
way that never existed before.
And what you were saying about like the
guy in the truck as you were saying that,
I was thinking one of
the things that I really,
yeah, we were earlier talking about a
radio lab and I, I said I was Sorta,
I found it sort of annoying
how produced it is.
I think one of the things that's cool
about your show, my show Dunkin show,
these conversational shows that
aren't highly produced and edited,
is that that guy in the truck,
he's listening to us,
have a conversation in real time.
So it's really easy for him to
imagine himself participating.
Whereas if you're listening to something
where everything's cut in real tight
and you know controlled,
you can't insert yourself into that
world because that's not a real world.
Maybe that's why I like radio lab is
cause I'm so used to this and I do this so
often.
I'm doing this three times,
sometimes four times even we've done five
a week on some weeks that when I go to
something like radio lab,
I could just sit down and absorb the
information and also because I think it's
so good. It's great. There's so
much matters. It's incredible.
But I could see your point. Like
sometimes it annoys me when they edit,
like someone's in the middle of
talking and then they'll explain in a
paraphrased way what that
guy actually wound up saying.
Well how about you let him say it?
Right? Like why did you have to chime in?
And we missing 10 15
seconds of his explanation.
Is it too verbose? Like
why, why you got to cut in?
But they're doing it because
they kind of liked doing that.
They like being clever with the
sound. That's their art. I mean,
they're creating this thing like my,
one of my all time favorites is Dan
Carlin's hardcore history. It's amazing.
We've heard the newest one. Oh
good Lord. It might be best Africa.
We just out what, what's the doubt
about the Assyrians? All my God.
Oh my God. It's good. He's great. Oh,
he's the best. You had them on your, yes.
I love that guy.
He's a fucking national treasure.
He makes people think about history and
in a way it's exciting and it's, it's,
it's a, you could digest it, you know?
Yeah. I was, I was, uh,
taking a walk the other day and I
was listening to one of his, um,
the series about world
war one and yeah, it's amazing.
Something of doom. Yeah.
Um, no. Uh, that prophets of doom I think
was the one about, um, here, I'll pull it.
It's like a seven, seven part series.
Each one's two or three hours long.
But it has always, I was
listening, I was thinking how,
cause I used to think history was boring,
right when I was in high school.
It was like, yeah, fucking history class
for Armageddon. That's what, that's it.
Yeah. All about world war one.
Oh my God. Incredible Shit.
And like the way he tells the story and
the details of the research is like,
this is the most interesting shit I can
imagine listening to and history was
boring. Like how hard you have to
work to make this boring. Well,
I think there's a difference between has,
I mean it's one of the reasons why he
makes the distinction that he's not a
historian. You know, he's like,
and although I do consider him one,
he won't consider himself
one because he's so humble.
But what he's doing is he's adding this,
the dramatic flare of a professional
broadcaster and then really excellent one
and that really excellent,
um, uh, entertainer
and he's, he's distributing how
to use this voice. Well, yeah,
he's so good dramatically with his
paws and winning quotes, you know,
he changes his voice fucking good. The
new one's even better than the other ones.
I think he's getting better as that
sounds and Danieli Bolelli now it's in the
ring. That's true. Yeah. Yeah. He was just
fucking love that guy.
And his new podcast is really excellent
to the beginning of the first one.
It's just like self,
it's about a story.
And that he had actually told me on
the podcast and I remember saying,
what the hell? Yeah, I do. I explain
it to anybody cause I don't want to,
I don't want to blow any of the suspense
and the craziness of the first story,
but not zero, zero, which is a
kind of, when he's explaining it,
but episode one block,
that story's so twisted when you find
out what people were capable of doing to
each other. Just a few hundred
a thousand, 2000 years ago.
Right now we're blowing up
people in Yemen. I mean,
and they say only 10% of the people who
get blown up are the ones we're aiming
at. 90% are innocent
bystanders. Yeah, yeah.
Well I mean this drones in this book I'm
almost finished with now the argument
is that civilization is sick,
right? Civilization itself
is a sick system. Um,
partly because it's built
on the repression of natural
urges and then you know,
all this distortion and all that.
So when you look at like all these stories
that people are talking about their
world war one, we don't even know what
they're fighting about, right. You know,
and the poison in each other and they're
blowing shit up and they're destroying
the landscape and it's dropping tons
of munitions and all this shit. And uh,
or Columbus, when Columbus landed,
you know, he'd fucking, you know,
the letter he wrote back to the queen
when he first landed and he spend Yola was
like, these people are so
beautiful and they're so generous.
If you express admiration for anything,
they just give it to you.
And there's food everywhere
and fish everywhere and
fruit and they're beautiful.
The swim and they're half
naked and they're lovely,
lovely people with 50 soldiers,
we can enslave the entire population.
It's like, Oh, who civilized here? You
know, the guy who's like, fuck you.
And he's cutting off people's hands cause
they're not bringing them enough gold
and there is no goal.
And then they're sending the dogs on
them and watching them rip their guts out
and slam and babies against
trees were the civilized ones.
Then it was all break explained in really
great detail by some religious person
that was involved with that.
Right.
What was his position? What would,
he was a Jesuit and he wrote, um,
the conquest, the conquest
of new Spain was, uh,
Diaz. That's a really interesting
book that's about, uh,
the Aztec thing where they went
and took over Montezuma. But, uh,
de Las Casas was a Jesuit who
saw this happening and um,
the wrote all these treaties,
treaties is,
or essays decrying the treatment
of the natives and he's, he,
his point was like,
they're human beings and we're not
treating them like human beings.
And then supple Veda argued they're not
human beings, they don't have souls.
So we're free to do what we want.
And they had this famous debate at the
Vatican between those two perspective.
Like are they human or not?
Are they, you know, do,
are we justified in treating them like
animals and a de Las Casas one but didn't
matter. You know, my question is it's
pretty much universally accepted.
The Columbus was a con. Yeah. And
that he was a horrible evil person.
But how did it take us until
2015 before we recognize that?
How the fuck did that guy get a Monday?
Well, how did he get a day off? The same,
same reason.
The fucking,
those heads are carved into the
black hills in South Dakota, right?
It's like it was what we were saying
earlier, assist them once as if,
as if it's a living thing is system
adopts the subsystems that perpetuated a,
so that's a good way of describing
it. You know, you're an expensive, uh,
empire system. So you celebrate
those who expanded the empire.
It doesn't matter if they
were cons, right? Right.
Because what they did is something
that serve the interest of the system.
And so when I'm trying to get at in this
book is that what serves the interest
of the system is not what serves the
interest of the individuals within the
system. So the fact that,
you know, people often say,
well obviously the human race
is amazing because you know,
so successful because look,
there's 7 billion of us now and there
were only a hundred million 500 years ago,
whatever it is. And my argument
is like, well wait a minute.
Like they're way more prisoners in
America now than there were 50 years ago.
Does that mean prisoners are thriving?
You know,
the fact that there are more of a
given species doesn't mean that that
individuals within that species are living
better than premium. Not at all. It's,
it's also the same sort
of logic that would say,
well obviously being a king and being
royal is special and these are special
people. That's why they have power
over all these other people. Like, no,
these are the people just don't have
any power. Right. There's only you,
you're the king.
Like they,
that's a stupid way of looking at it and
the system gives you that power and you
just happened to have been plugged
into that spot. Yeah. Yeah.
And the idea that this is the
only way to do things well,
this is because we are
the best of version.
Like if you want to look at America as
far as like productivity and innovation,
and we're the best version right
now currently on this planet.
But that doesn't mean this
is the best way to do it.
And it doesn't mean that if we found a
planet somewhere that was filled with
human beings that spoke a language
that we could all understand,
but they just lived fucking way more
harmonious than us. They had no garbage.
Everything was completely recycled.
There was never any waste.
They kept a very strict, uh, uh,
understanding of their environment and
what they were doing to it and how many
babies they had and how they treated
each other.
And they never allowed property to exist.
They never allowed extreme depression
or any things that we have that we just
push aside or throw pills at, are
fucking put fences up for. We would go,
oh my God were retarded.
Why didn't we live like this?
And we could live like this and small
sustainable groups like these tribes that
we were talking about,
right?
We're talking about the way they would
take care of the village and then
everybody would take care of each other
and they'd live in these harmonious
communities. And it's not
saying they don't have disputes.
It's not saying they don't disagree
about things because all people are
constantly debating about ideas and they
all have their own unique and different
perspectives.
But when we get to this gigantic group,
whether it's a 300 million in
America or 7 billion worldwide,
there's this massive diffusion
of responsibility for the
residual effects of our
civilization.
It's cigarettes out the window and fucking
poop in the ocean or whatever it is.
Like we somehow under the don't
feel responsible for all that.
Although ultimately it comes from humans.
If we found some group
that had figured that out,
we found some planet that was filled with
people that didn't have anything that
we don't have. They had
computers, they had cars,
but they had figured all this other shit
out and they had just, they just say,
well, this is more important than
anything else we're doing. Let's,
let's engineer this first.
Let's figure this out.
First we would realize that we're
living like apes with phones and guns.
That's where it,
yeah,
like I had this joke in part of the
joke was about like if we went to, uh,
to the zoo or went to the Congo, we
found some rare spot in the Congo and we,
we ran into these chimps and they had
figured out cell phones and rocket
launchers,
but all they were doing is taking
pictures of their dicks and shooting each
other in the face would be like,
what? That's us are you guys do it?
But that is us. That is us. That is what
we're doing. It's true. I mean, we're not,
it's,
we're not only taking pictures of our
dicks and knowing only shooting each other
in the face,
but for doing a lot of it,
there's a lot of Dick pics and there's a
lot of people getting shot in the face.
And a lot of it is die.
Robots that are flying around the sky,
killing 90% of the wrong people.
Well, sex and, and military are
the two main drivers of economics,
right? I mean, yeah. The
W is Eo Wilson said, uh,
he's great biologist.
He said humans are, uh,
the tragedy of humanity is that
we have stone-age instincts,
medieval institutions and god,
like powers technology.
That's a beautiful way describing it.
Yeah. Yeah. And it's, it's a mess.
Yeah. I mean what you described
like, oh, we go to this,
this planet and find these people.
And then that's very similar to the
story that is told over and over and over
again at first contact between
civilized people and native people.
Now when I say native people,
keep in mind,
I look at the Aztecs or the Inca
as they're civilized, right? It's,
it's not European, but they're living in
hierarchical, large scale civilizations.
Agricultural civilization, right?
Yeah. They're, they're native. Yeah.
Might not know about a lot of the
things of the Europeans knew about.
And they probably can choose that
shit out of slaves and all that shit.
So I'm not so, cause a lot of times
people will be like, Oh man, you know,
the fucking hystrix ripped their hearts.
I'm not,
the Aztecs are the same as the Spaniards,
right.
I'm talking about Nate low scale a hunter
gatherer bands where everybody knows
each other, right. And nomadic, right.
Which in is tribal people oftentimes it
live in jungles and things along those
lines. There's a lot of resources
and there's no fight for resource.
Yeah. Because the population is standing
is, and it's steady. Right, right.
Um, you know, there are all
sorts of reasons for that,
but that's the story you get. Again and
again in this book, I quote this, um,
this Jesuit who lived with a Munton
Yay Indians in what's now Quebec.
And he says like,
you know,
they really enjoy life and
they're not worried about dying.
They're not worried about being hungry
because they save the world provides for
them. They look around,
they're like, yeah, there's
food everywhere. And he says,
like, I tried to talk to them and they,
if they get a beaver, they have a feast.
Even if you know the, the, the
guys next door got a beaver in,
they're having a feast to,
and if they get three beavers,
they'll have three fees and it
just eat till everything's gone.
And when I say to them like, why don't
you save something for tomorrow? They say,
well, we'll catch something tomorrow. And
they're like, well, what if you don't?
Well then we'll be hungry. Don't
worry. I mean, it's no big deal there.
There's always enough.
Well,
they lived in a different world to
where there wasn't as massive fucking
quantity of human beings
that are literally pulling
everything out of the land.
Yeah.
So you need that huge population
to support the scarcity mindset.
Well,
here's one good example of information
being distributed and how it's benefiting
even the environment here in North
America at the turn of the century,
there was a point in time where we had
wiped out like a giant majority of the
game animals on this planet because just
like they did with the buffalo and they
just fucking slaughtered the buffalo
and buffalo bill is a national hero.
All right. You're talking about
Columbus. Sure. Full of fucking bill.
That's what he's famous for. Shot
him and left them there to rot. Yeah.
What'd they do? They took
the hides, right? That's all
they, that's all they talk.
And mostly it was just to starve the
Indians. The hides were like, yeah,
that's why they did it.
Because they were,
that's when they were building the
railroads across the great plains.
Indians kept kicking their ass and
so they're like, well, you know,
they're kicking our ass so let's starve
them out. Take away their food source.
Yeah. You know, it's also interesting,
we haven't reintroduced the Buffalo,
like the buffalo is the one animal that
if you look at like they've reintroduced
wolves.
All right.
And to a great many people's
dismay because they're
starting to attack livestock.
But that livestock in and of itself
is one of the reasons why they haven't
reintroduce buffalo.
Right?
Because people are scared because
if they bring buffalo back,
buffalo are beautiful, majestic creatures,
but say goodbye it all your hey bitch.
Well, buffaloes use much
less water. Cows do. Oh
yeah, they're much better
environmental. Well they can. I mean,
they're fucking hardy. Hardy are. And
they can withstand really cold. Oh yeah.
Will they have blankets? They're
built in blankets, but they eat a lot.
Have you seen one like in la? All
in? Only in like a fenced in area.
It's like a Mousse. It's like wow,
that's so big. Yeah. Yeah. Bigger. Even.
Well not only that,
they look like prehistoric wooly and
Florian is a crazy thing called the muskox
Tibet. Well they have them in um, um, uh,
Antarctic I believe it is.
And they also have them in Greenland
and people go to Greenly hunting these
things and they apparently
tasted delicious like rib eyes.
Like they're marbled cause there's
got the long hair, right? Yeah.
But they look like, like star wars
creatures look like a real animal,
this big furry thing with horns and
it's running around and the frozen snow,
you're like,
what the fuck is that?
But these animals can survive in places
where we couldn't imagine surviving and
they thrive out there.
And this frozen Tundra,
these big gigantic,
you know,
2000 pound beast covered and far and god,
it's amazing.
But what my point was that there was a
point in time where we had driven a giant
majority of these animals to extinction.
Now because of the symbiotic relationship,
especially like white tail deer have
with agriculture and human settlement,
there's more deer in America today than
they were when Columbus was here. Right.
Which is nuts.
And it's because of intervention.
It's because of management is
because like these, these, uh,
fishing game groups if recognize the
problems and if regulated the amount of a
hunting that people can do,
but also worked really hard to
protect habitat and preserve habitat.
And that's one of the things with
these national forests. In fact,
Teddy Roosevelt was one cause he was a,
an avid outdoorsman and a hunter.
He is the reason why we have these
national forests and national parks.
He and with great resistance,
he put that in place and he turned on
his own class. He was an interesting cat.
His mother and his wife died on
either the same day or the same week.
Whoa. Yeah, he had a really bad week.
Um, it might've been the same day,
but he was back in New York.
I think he was a governor or a senator
and like his fucking life fell apart and
he's from this really wealthy family,
right? Obviously the Roosevelts,
they were already a very
wealthy family and as a way,
a little bit like Wim Hoff and as
a way of dealing with his grief,
he was like, fuck it, I'm out of here.
He quit. And he went out to Montana,
I think, and worked on a
ranch and he was a sick kid.
Um, which is why he sort of
like over compensated in a
way with all the macho and
you know, all this stuff. And he worked
on that ranch. That's where he really
fell in love with the natural
world and you know, it became this.
And then he went back and became
secretary of the navy, I think, and uh,
fought in the Spanish
American war and you know,
his political career took off from there.
He established an independent party
wasn't like the Buffalo Party or something
like that. Wasn't that one of the
Times that he ran for president? Yeah.
It was in buffalo though, is like the
Bull Moose Moose. Right, right, right.
Yeah, that's right. And he and John Muir,
we're friends who is John Muir again,
a great naturalist who wrote about
Yosemite and convinced a Roosevelt to make
Yosemite national park,
maybe the first national park.
Isn't it ironic that that's
probably what's going to
kill every single person on
this entire continent?
When Yosemite blows on that motherfucker
in Yellowstone, Yellowstone,
you choose those two for
whatever easy yellow, the y.
That's fucking goddamn terrifying to
me. Yeah, that's a big one. That's,
that's pretty cool.
There's always love that shit.
Did you see that storm yesterday?
Oh yeah. It was beautiful. I like,
I like when nature just says,
fuck you.
You know that was barely a fuck you.
That was like, no, but first la,
that was whether it was like I was,
I was sitting up in the Soho House.
You've been up there in Hollywood? No,
I never have. It's pretty cool.
It's like it's the top floor of,
and it's up on the hill anyway.
So you can see all the way to the
ocean where all the rich people,
they become like members of this place.
And it's like a status symbol spot. Yeah.
Why'd you get in there?
Cause I have rich status symbol friends.
What is it like in there?
It's cool. It's nice.
I mean there are no cameras allowed.
So like what happens if
you pull out your phone?
Actually what happened yesterday
when that storm system came in, I'll,
I'll show you a picture. You
know when we, when he finished,
but it was so beautiful because it was
really late and the sun was like right on
the horizon and these crazy clouds
came in really quickly and then it was
raining and the sun and there were
rainbows and like, you know the,
when the rays of the sun come down and
you know something's Jacob's ladder,
I think it's called. So everybody was like
pictures and all the waiters are like,
no photos, no photos. And
everyone's like, fuck you,
we're doing this soho rebellion.
Yeah.
But nobody first celebrities,
they do it right because they didn't want
people like surreptitiously look, look,
Joe Rogan talking to somebody.
But it's so hard when you have a phone
with a camera and everyone has a phone.
Everyone's phone as a camera.
You're not supposed to pull out the
phone in the place that you can go out on
the terrace where you can smoke and
whatever and talk and text or whatever.
So they ask you when you go there,
please do not use your
phone while you're eating.
Can you taxed while you're eating?
I don't think you're supposed to have
your phone out of your pocket in sign,
but everybody's got a computer. They have
a computer. Yeah, everybody's working.
Cause it's a place where you can go
and work all day and there are tables.
It's like a lounge. Yeah. Yeah. You can
get some food, have a coffee, but you
can sit there. Is it like a restaurant
as well? I thought it was, yeah.
There's a rat in the,
in the back there's a restaurant area,
but the main thing like
there's a pool table there.
It's like a cool place to hang out.
But we're all the like she,
she people hang out.
Well honestly,
I mean I probably been there
five or 10 times and you know,
I can't remember seeing anyone that I
recognized as being famous wealthy folks.
I think it's,
it's people in the entertainment business.
So there are a lot of producers and
scream screenwriters and you know,
and some actors will go in there,
whatever. But I think the idea,
it's not like my impression anyway is
that it's not about like going and being
seen. It's about going and not
having to deal with the shit,
but still being in public. So you can
be in public, people will be cool.
They respect your privacy, you can hang
out and work, you can have meetings there,
you can, you know, do your business
there, whatever. And also it's a network.
There's one in New York, there's one
in London. I've heard of them before,
but I've always thought
that they were just like,
like Hob knobbing celebrity
spot. So since you know me, Joe,
I could probably talk to someone that
gets you out of want to go. This is,
I'm a member of the comedy store,
the only club I want to go to know.
There's this a weird thing about
being in that sort of a circle of like
privileged folks that I try
to avoid as much as possible.
It's a lot of people enjoy that a little
too much and it becomes like something
that they, uh, they, they just,
it's just become something a
little too precious to them. Yeah.
I don't get that vibe there,
but maybe I'm just not paying attention.
I'm only getting it third hand through
people that know people that go there,
that want to become a part of it and they
talk about, I'm like, what is this? What?
Then I realized I can't be in this
conversation. I got to get out of here.
I feel that way about Americans.
Actually,
when I'm in Spain and I hear
American accents, I'm like, yeah,
I'm going to go down here. Nothing
against Americans. But you know,
when, I mean, I don't know if I'm
resonating with what you're talking about,
but it's like I know that world too.
Well,
I'm not here to be in that world.
I want to be in another world was also
think that there's a certain amount of
reaching for,
uh,
for things that some folks will
do when they achieve a level of,
uh,
financial success.
And they still feel like empty as
they want some sort of exclusivity.
So they like to go to the admirals lounge,
you know what I mean?
At the airport. And you know
what I mean? Like this hat.
But the other thing to get with the
hats, but you know what I mean? Sure.
There's like exclusive things
that make them feel special.
Vip Lounge. Yeah. Yeah. God,
I want to get a bottle service
behind the velvet rope. Ooh.
Well that's when you know you've, you're,
you know, you're, you're a sucker for it.
That's when you're hooked. People love
that velvet rope. It's right there.
I can't even get through it.
Look at it as a barrier.
It's like a forced to tell you
what the guy I was with, uh,
he's a really good friend of mine. He's a
wonderful guy. Uh, grew up in Hollywood.
He's right now,
he's homeless.
He's given up his apartment cause
he's doing this movie about dolphins.
So he's down in Florida a lot of times
and then he's in Mexico and he's doing
all this stuff. And uh, I'm not, I hope
I haven't said enough to give him away,
but he's like, he's essentially, I was
giving him shit. He's a pussy vagabond.
He's like sleeping with different women
every night and he's using their houses.
Yeah, that's gross. No, they're all
friends and they, all they'll know is,
they all know about each other, so he's
not lying to anyone, but he's like, yeah,
when I'm in La,
I don't really need an apartment.
I can stay in a hotel if I went to,
but it usually I'm sleeping with one of
my friends and then I go to the so house
and that's where I work. And it's like,
all right, that's a pretty good system,
you know.
And then he has his computer.
He works there and then he's off
to Miami to do some more filming.
I have a buddy who's a,
a wealthy real estate guy and his house
is basically a hostel for really hot,
semi
semi homeless girls.
Like a Charles Manson without the
killing. No, no, no, because like,
it's always like some new one that is
living with them and they almost always
have like a little dog and they're like,
they just get kicked out of their
apartment and no, you could stay with me.
And then when I'm staying with him
and it's like this battle he has to,
he's an older guy and he was like,
shit, it was hard for him to fuck them.
You know, occasionally he does get the
fuck, but sometimes I'm like, dude,
you got to get away from her. What are
you doing? She's fucking, but it's,
that's what he does.
He has like one after another of
these like semi homeless girls,
they don't have any place to go.
And they wind up staying with him
and they were usually really hot.
And that's their currency. The currency
is that they're pretty and, but you know,
symbiotic in a sad skirt away.
Yeah.
Do you ever hear a video about Father
Yod, Father Yod? Just talk about that.
It's called the, the,
uh, the source family.
He was this doot. Oh, you should watch
that. That's a really interesting,
so he was this documentary.
Yeah, it's a document,
I think it's called the source family.
And so father Yod was this dude who
started the first vegetarian restaurant in
America and he was in Hollywood and it
became like a place where Goldie Hawn or
some, you know, I don't know. People
in the early sixties were going and uh,
it'd be, you know, Dennis Hopper
and that kind of scene. Right.
And then it became a cult and he ended
up like basically marrying like 30 women
or something. But he was this big
charismatic dude. He was like,
Charles Manson without the nastiness,
right. Check out the movie.
It'll blow your mind.
I won't tell you any more because like,
it takes turns that you don't see coming.
And it tells you a lot about what la was
like in the sixties and seventies well,
oh,
I was like,
I mean the whole country was thrown on
its head in the 60s like no one knew what
the fuck to expect as soon as that acid
and marijuana got into the system post
Vietnam or during Vietnam?
During Vietnam. The whole system
went wacky. Yeah. And he was,
I mean you'll relate to him in some ways
cause he was like physically he was a
really serious dude.
Like he was a green baret I think.
And he had killed a couple of people
and then he like spun out into drug
addiction or alcohol or something
and then he got his shit together.
But he was just so fucking charismatic
that like people just gathered around him
all the time.
But at that,
if you watch it and we'll talk further,
I don't want to say anything else because
I'm really interested in Netflix or
apple. Yeah. It's somewhere out there.
The source fan source family and
also that Verner Herzog thing,
encounters at the end of the world.
I don't mean to be giving you homework,
homework that's,
and you like her.
It's this same pad.
Has Sierra Lynch on it for the last time
you were here? Like my brain is not.
Yeah. Is this your, like
when Chris Ryan's here?
I guess I haven't been
writing that many notes.
I mean there's other notes that aren't
from here. Oh, well I'm honored man.
And you're taking some notes.
The end of the world.
What does it encounters ferner
her to see the one about, um,
the, uh, the cave art
in three d, You know,
I've been to less SCO in the real
cave was crazy only with an official
invitation from the French
government. Yeah. Because, um,
the people affected with
their breathing. Yeah. Yeah.
That was a crazy day, man.
That was, that was awhile ago.
I'm like looking at those things in person
and knowing that someone 40,000 years
ago or whatever, 25 unless Sko, but
some of them, some of them are 40.
The writing on this wall that
long ago, like a bowl, right?
It's the bison and it's like
as big as that wall behind you.
It's like three or four meters long and
maybe two or three meters high and it's
red ochre.
Wow.
It's just extraordinary because like
as her talk shows in that movie,
they use the contour of the rock to
accentuate the contours of the body of the
animal.
So like there's a bulge in the rock and
that's in the shoulder of the bison and
the fucking amazing. But I'll
tell you that. I mean, let's go.
It's a real honor to be invited.
And it was only because I was with Stanley
Kripner and Stanley goddess invited
his assistant doing, he's
already, he's in China right now.
Stoppable they invite him every year to
go to China and speak about shamanism,
I think. Wow. He was an interesting guy.
I was really fascinating
when you brought him in here.
He's really fascinated by listening to
his words and I'm really glad you did
that too because he's, you
know, he's 85 or something.
He's not going to be
around forever. But, uh,
he's really underappreciated because he's,
he's published 25 books and 700
scientific papers and you know,
but he never saw it.
The media
or anything. But he was on the
Johnny Carson show a few times.
What's he really about?
What? Well, he was the guy,
he was like the go to guy in the late
sixties early seventies when you were
talking about psychics. So like he
would go with the amazing Kreskin,
you know, do you remember the amazing
crush spoon bending and all that.
So they would have doctor crib neuron
to sort of, you know, monitor the,
the experiment and you know,
try to catch Kreskin and lay
his trickery and all this stuff.
And so yeah,
I joke with Stanley that his Rolodex
has like three people under the amazing,
the amazing Randy, the amazing
Kreskin and some other amazing,
amazing Randy.
He's a fascinating cat too cause he sort
of set out to try to disprove as much
of that shit as possible even
though that's how he started out.
Well he's a magician as, as Stanley. Yeah.
So magicians are really skeptical because
they make a living tricking people so
they know how easy it is to do. When I did
that, a Scifi show, we had this guy on,
his name is Ben a check and he's
fucking amazing. If that shit amazing.
I mean he did the spoon bending
thing right in front of my,
I couldn't figure out what
the hell he was doing,
but he's super adamant about what he does.
What I'm doing is just tricks, right?
These are tricks. I don't have any powers.
This is, I can't tell you how I'm doing
it because this is my thing and I'm,
I'm you know, making a living doing
this. But I'll tell you right now,
it's bullshit. I'm really good at
this bullshit, but it's bullshit.
But I mean he was amazing.
And when he would pull information out
of people about their childhood and
guests things and explain where
they came from and like how,
it was just like mind blowing. And I'm
like, how the fuck are you doing? This?
Wouldn't say, but he would say,
I'm not telling you I'm doing this,
but I'm telling you right now, I'm
not psychic. This is all fakery.
It's all bullshit.
But he would get furious when he would
like the long island medium or one of
those shows where they had people and
tell them about their dead relatives.
He's like, this is, these
are crooks, these are, these
are, these people are shit.
Like they're ruining people.
They're stealing money from people with
their trickery and the people who are
grieving, vulnerable. Come
on. And I look in the, Ah, ah,
that's the saddest shit
about people that are,
that go after folks that are hurting,
you know,
like with their loss and then they say
he's talking to you from behind the,
beyond the grave.
I feel like he's reaching out to you
and he's happy with where you are and he
just wants you to,
there's something that you're about to do.
Is there something you're thinking about
doing all this, this business project?
Yes. That's, that's it. That's it.
Yeah. And the fucking monsters. Okay.
Then extrapolate from that to the
American medical system where 30% of all
Medicaid is spent in the
last month of people's lives.
Does that really the amount? I
think so. Meanwhile, mushrooms,
it could grow mushrooms. It's giving
them that a fraction. Is that,
what is it when you're doing a hip
replacement on a 90 year old blind lady?
Fucking
again, you know, or you know it. No,
there's this experimental treatment
we can try on grandma. You know,
it's going to like all her hair's gonna
fall out and she won't be able to see,
but you know, we'll get $40,000 from your
insurance company. It's the same thing,
you know,
it's so fucking
sense in that sense. The dying
people, they mean there's
a, there's a lack of, uh,
accepting of the futility
of the body failing.
But didn't they just pass assisted
suicide in California like,
or the ability to Jerry
Brown just signed it. I mean,
I think that's important too,
because I think we put our dogs down.
My dogs are sick and suffering. We know
that they're 15 years old and there's no,
there's no positive ending to this,
but we don't do with people.
We make people like naturally rot away.
And I know there's this,
there's a potential for fuckery and for
people that want inheritance money and
the you talk your elderly dad who's got
Alzheimer's into signing over some will
just before you fucking off him.
There's a lot of that that's real.
It's 100% I know a guy who found out
that his own brother had talked his mom
into signing a fucking new will and he
had a fight him in court over it while it
was mom's sick.
His mom was like,
she's got some sort of a neurological
disorder and she's completely out of it.
And he,
he did this while his mom was sick.
He was taking care of his mom and he
had to hurt. I mean it was fucking,
as soon as it was horrible,
horrible people out there that do,
do things like that and they could do
something like that and then put someone
down.
But on the other hand,
like why would you want someone to just
suffer in fucking complete and total
agony for the remaining five months,
six months,
their life so that you can rest easy in
the fact that they went out with God,
they went out
naturally outweigh fighting.
You know,
after a long fight with like why
is fighting so admirable? What,
what happened to like gracefully
accepting the fact that we're all mortal,
especially. It's not like, well grandpa
fought it and then he lived forever.
He Won. He Won. He went back
in time. Now he's 20 you know,
Grandpa is getting younger every year.
It's so strange.
He just started competing in gymnastics,
so it's amazing.
He's going to stop shaving soon.
What about,
what about hermetically sealed
stainless steel caskets? Oh yeah,
that's what's up with that.
Like what exactly is it that your
ceiling out or in, I'm not sure what,
which way the seals preserve him
from nature. Well, wouldn't you want,
I mean like this ashes to ashes,
dust to dust. Don't you want, don't you
want them to be absorbed by the earth?
Don't do it. The, the,
they're the skin vessel to be useful and
maybe a tree will grow underneath them
or,
that's what I'm saying about American
Cultured Dab, Duh. Right. Denial, anger,
bargaining, depression, acceptance.
Do you think the culture's stuck,
but do you think that's
changing, do you think? Do,
and I think largely because this
conversations like this, you know,
I think largely because of
people able to communicate
with each other and express how
futile that is and ridiculous that is
because that's the kind of thing,
if you know,
if you're a parent or grandparent is or,
or husband or wife is facing this kind of
thing and you're, you're thinking, fuck,
you know, I could put the dog down.
I can't help my wife die in peace.
Know you're not going to say
that to anyone. You get arrested,
you'll get ostracized. But we
can say it publicly. You know,
some people somewhere say is fuck it.
This is the truth.
Like in the book I quote from
a doctor's and you look at how,
what choices doctors make for
themselves when they're dying. Oh.
Versus what they recommend to their
patients. Completely different.
Yeah.
I have access easy cause they
know CPR rarely does anything.
When you're 80 years old and you have
a heart attack, say CPR, you know,
might keep you pumping along
for another couple of weeks,
but you'll have brain damage, broken
ribs and you know, excruciating pain.
A CPR works great. And movies, and
actually I quote those stats on TV,
the,
you know,
the number of people who go home and lead
a healthy life after receiving CPR is
like 95% and in reality it's like 6% yeah.
So it's, it's a funny,
so funny, but you know,
getting back to the people
you're saying who, you know,
sign this and then often what are
the question I have is like, are we,
are we making there are creeps
who will do that shit, right?
There are situations that are really ugly,
but by our refusal to openly talk
about this stuff and make these things
available,
are we empowering them or not?
Because the assumption is that
they would have more power.
But I think if you have an open adult
conversation about these things in a
government that acknowledges that
sometimes the right thing to do is to help
someone die without pain and the
hospice gets funded a lot and all that.
I think that this enables those people.
It disempowers them because
then grandma's getting,
when she's still got her shit together,
there's going to be more
open about talking about it.
There's going to be more advanced
directive signed. People are going to be,
you know, it's like sex where
the abstinence only programs,
those are the states where the most
STDs are pregnancies, teen pregnancies.
Right. So you refuse to talk
about it. You just make it worse.
[inaudible] yeah,
that it only makes sense in that sense.
And I know that's a double,
but I think that what's going on now
that has never existed before is that our
culture is not just being shaped
by whatever media is projected.
For the longest time, our culture was
shaped by the people that surrounded us.
You know? And that's why leaders were so
important. Right. And the tribal cultures,
tribal elders and Shamans and the
people that had lived a long life and it
learned and you could listen to them
and they could explain these experiences
that they've gone through and perhaps
you're going to go through rites of
passages were also very important
for that same reason like you've got,
you're going to go through something
and experience something and then you'll
have a greater understanding
of the world because of that.
And for the longest time in our,
in our most recent history,
you know, it's the longest
time of, for us pretty recent,
but the last few hundred years it was
either a books that gave us a depiction of
the world and we kind of
learned from that and said,
well this is obviously how the world goes.
Or then it became motion pictures and
television and father knows best and you
know,
all these different shows that sort of
gave us this idea or ideal of what life
is all about.
And that's where we've formed our
vision or our version of reality.
But now it's different.
Like now our version of realities
is informed by conversations.
Our version of reality is being formed
by people communicating with each other
and it's just a completely different
sort of experience because now you're
seeing a broader,
wider sort of conversation going on with
whether or not this like it just even
movements that are extreme like,
like whether it's paid or whether it's
a animal rights organizations or uh,
uh,
gay rights organizations or trans rights
or whether these like these black lives
matter or these other,
there's all these different groups
that have like way broader reach with
activism. That event, it
was never possible before.
Like if you didn't have a
guy like Martin Luther King,
a charismatic leader that could speak
up and give speeches. I have a dream.
Like if you didn't have that guy, who
the fuck else do you have? So few voices.
But now anyone with a concept or an
idea that resonates with other people,
you can make a tweet and that tweet can
go viral and that viral tweak and shape
the way people look at a certain subject.
You could write a Facebook blog or a
tumbler blog or make a short youtube video
and people could watch that video
and see your perspective. Go God.
And he's right.
Chris Ryan made a great point there and
then they exchange it and they spread it.
Send him money, send that motherfucker
sub cash, pay pal, that dude's in cash.
You know this, but this, this the
unique time where we can all sort of,
we can all aid and shaping our culture.
We can all aid in shaping our
view of the world that we live in.
That just wasn't available before.
It just wasn't available.
What are you going to mimeograph on?
Million pamphlets and pass them out best
you could become one of those people
that shapes it for everybody else.
Like you'd be counter circle. Well,
even if you make a movie, you know,
or if you make a write a book,
but even then the movie is going
to be censored by the money.
Now you can make an independent movie
with $20,000 in your fucking iPhone. Yeah,
it's great. Yeah, you don't even,
and then you could do it through a go
fund me or a Kickstarter or some shit.
You don't need anybody's help. I mean,
we live in a weird, weird time. It's a,
it's amazing,
but I feel like we don't appreciate
it or can't recognize how insanely
transformative it is
because we're a part of it.
I think like one day in the future,
they'll look back at the 21st
century and they'll look back,
particularly at the time from,
you know,
the year 2000 I think maybe even 2001
maybe September 11th would be like a
tipping point because of all the
chaos that went along with that.
And they'll look at the amount of change
that's taking place in the last 14
years, since September 11 and they'll
go, this fucking put this will,
what a whirlwind of change
and ideas and transformation.
And in the middle of it,
we're,
we're just in the middle of it with our
iPhones and you're fucking, you know,
youtube and periscope and all this crazy
shit is going on and we're not even
realizing how bizarre it is.
Well,
I mean, I don't know if you're,
how you're younger than me,
but I remember in 1992 I lived in
San Francisco and I had a computer,
a Compaq,
and the Internet was starting and I was
in graduate school and I had come from
Spain to go to do graduate school in San
Francisco and the Internet was starting
and this graduate school, uh, didn't
want to incorporate the Internet.
They were like, Nah, that's it. You know,
it's bullshit. Right. And I was like,
if you guys would use this, I could
go back to Spain, you know? Like,
that was my idea. It's like this is going
to be big, this internet thing. You know,
you thought that even then that it
would be like a global thing. I thought,
I mean, I was thinking of it
in terms of my own life, right?
Because I'd wanted to be back in Spain.
I was living with a Spanish woman.
She missed her family and like
we were like Cha, you know,
I want to get an American degree but I,
I really like living in Spain and she
wants to give it. And I was like, fuck,
if I could like submit papers this way
and the professors could answer through
the Internet and we could like do this
whole thing and I could be in Spain.
And I remember getting really frustrated
that they were just like, dad,
this isn't,
this isn't going to happen.
That shows the difference
between you and me. With me.
When I first got on the Internet,
it was 1994 all I did
was download UFO reports,
ca porn. I was looking for
porn. I was like of report to.
But it was frustrating because
it was like click, click, click.
Oh there's nice top of her breasts.
And I was single and living by myself.
So I just would go to the DVD store,
fucking rush those beads aside like
a gangster and either rent them
only room,
sometimes they had saloon doors,
the doors apart and go into that and
everybody would be, would feel so guilty.
And the porn section.
Do you ever see a porn movie in a
theater with like a bunch of old men and
raincoat? No, no. I took my girlfriend
in high school. Oh well, you know,
they really cliche well boots.
I told you I have this super hot Cuban
girlfriend and my last year of high
school and uh,
we went to a dirty movie.
I think it was Debbie does Dallas. Oh
yeah. That's how old I am. And uh, yeah,
I remember taking her in and I remember
just like, it was like, you know,
like taking a chunk, seal meat
into a shark tank, you know,
it's just like the dudes are just like,
yeah,
we'll want a live one.
There it is. How cool
did you ever see,
um,
that when deep throat came out it was
essentially viewed as a cinematic film.
It wasn't like porn wasn't really a thing.
There was stag films which were just like
these weird weird clips on 16 million
meet early Jack Nicholson standing in
line in Times Square. Johnny Carson,
it was a famous photo of Johnny Carson
and all these people dressed up really
nice and they're waiting in
line to go see deep throat.
Have you seen the documentary inside deep?
Thorough now? Yeah. Well another one.
I'm expecting a report a
Monday morning by the way,
on the one with Lindsay Lohan,
right. No incident. She chief away.
It's a documentary about exactly what
you're saying about the cultural moment
that deep throat presented and how yeah.
Uh,
Lindsay Lohan play that role in a movie
that very few people watched that happen.
Um, Linda Lovelace. Yes. Yeah,
yeah. Poor Linda Lovelace.
Cause she then became a tool of the
feminist movement. She did. Yeah, she,
and then she claimed that she had
been raped and that the whole thing,
she didn't enjoy any of it.
And then at the end of her life,
I think she was diagnosed with cancer
and that at the end of her life she was
like, no, that was bullshit and
all convinced me to say that.
But really I was just having fun and it
was talking a lot of dicks. No big deal.
Yeah. Well, you know,
oftentimes people do become tools
of groups that have these, uh,
ideological principles that you may or
may not go with the idea of the feminist
movement.
And like th th the,
the real problem that a lot of people
have is that there's some women that are
involved in that,
that really don't like men and they're
opposed to men and they're opposed to,
there was one woman who was a part of,
I think it's called Google
ideas or something like that,
but she had this a
Twitter page and you know,
she was arguing with people on Twitter.
And one of the things she said is,
I men for dinner or eight men for
breakfast. Like, you think I'm scared,
I eat men for breakfast. And
everybody's like, what? What do you,
why would you say that? Like
all men, like not even assholes.
Like why would you even say that?
Like you imagine if a man said that if
a man in any position of power, like,
and she was,
I believe what,
and I'm parenting poor
understanding of what's going on.
But I believe that she was
brought in to sort of, um, uh,
bring more diversity to this project
they were doing, you know, this,
this idea and that bringing a feminist
perspective was going to, you know,
balance things out a little bit,
which is always a good idea. Right.
But when you read something
like that, like that's, if,
even if that's not really her intention,
just having that perspective,
having the perspective of a, you
know, I eat men for breakfast.
Like you could never say I was a nice way,
like come unwelcome.
I mean, hey, that's, that's
not bad. I like women who
have men for breakfast. Yeah.
You know, blow job.
There's the half asleep.
Blow job is a beautiful thing. It's
going away. It's like the Dodo bird.
It's like the wooded owl.
If we don't stop cutting down these
trees and we're not talking about doesn't
count because then you're not even there
for, it takes a special kind of passion.
And uh, I think, uh, some people just
don't have that for each other. Well,
and I think when you're half asleep
you can sort of enjoy it more
relaxed, more when you, you know,
you're cuddling together and then
someone just decides to start something.
You're like, all right, we're doing
this right. Ooh, well you do it.
I'll just sort of lie here sometimes
that's fun too. Yeah, sure, sure.
I did not consent. Well, there's like
a lot of madness now too, with sexy.
They want there, there were something
they were handing out to, um,
young students now where
they were saying that you,
you literally have to get consent. There
were, there were saying that they should,
you should get consent every 10
seconds during any, every, any sex act.
I'm sure there's an APP, you know, Siri,
ask her every 10 seconds, you know? Yeah.
If she's enjoying, do you consent
to this mass? Shove it in harder.
May I go faster, you know, may I pull it
back and then put it back in again, man.
Now rub it on the outside. May I tease
you man, we live in a world world. Yeah.
Well, it's America to have
you been to Spain? No, never.
You got to come visit man.
Well I think even it's not as suddenly
if you think it's really America.
I think it's what we were talking about
earlier about these small groups of
people that have these
ideas and they're very,
very passionate about
spreading these ideas.
And these ideas don't
necessarily have to be good,
but they have to have a bunch of other
crazy people that believe in them.
Like the people that convinced Linda
Lovelace in the saying that she was raped
and you know, the feminist movement
that co-opted her ideas. W I don't,
I mean they didn't do it because they
were calculating and evil and they had
some grand plan to ruin
it for everybody else.
They probably did it
because they were nuts.
And there's a lot of other nutty
people out there that agree with you.
I tweeted something the other day that
someone tweeted and it was so fucking
ridiculous that it, it, it,
it made me go, what the fuck?
I don't even know what to say, but
it was about abortion and the, uh,
the tweet was something like,
um,
abortion isn't just about women because
not everyone who gets pregnant is a
woman.
Hmm.
I'm not sure I get that one because
trans people can get pregnant.
So a woman who identifies with being
male can also get pregnant and abortion
rights are for her to
him him. Sorry, whatever.
Yeah, I'll read you or read you the exact
tweet because it's fucking maddening.
It's fucking crazy.
It just doesn't even make any sense.
And to find it right here. You found
a ready Jamie. Here it is right here.
I found it right here.
This is abortion.
Access isn't just a woman's right.
Not all pregnant people or people
who can get pregnant are women. What?
In the fucking actual
flux. But, but that's,
you can get a bunch of people
and go, yes, you're amazing.
Which he did is beautiful.
You just said was amazing. No,
but you said it's horse
shit like you just,
we just because you think
you're a man doesn't mean
you're a man. Okay, we're off.
We're off. On a weird tangent here,
but that's, that's what's going on.
Jermaine Greer got, and a lot of trouble
for saying that. Do you know who she is?
Yes. Yes. Correct. Yeah. The
female unit she wrote. Yeah.
So she said that she's like,
look, you can call yourself whatever you
want, but to me you're not a woman. Yeah.
And everybody's like, wow, hate language.
Languages are fucking opinion. Well,
not only that, like God damn it. Why?
Why do we assume that when
people say something nutty,
that they're crazy and almost every
single avenue except for gender,
for gender would just accept anything.
We'll just accept back and forth.
There's a guy that they
did speaking of radio lab,
an amazing piece and the guy clearly out
of his fucking mind when you listen to
him talk,
but he flips back and forth from being
male and female all day long and they're
talking about it like it's this
very unusual thing. It's very rare.
Normally with transgender they live in
one sacs and believe there are another,
but this person goes back and forth.
But when you listen to
this person talk you well,
this is not a stable human being.
Yeah,
and it's quite possible they
are out of their fucking mind.
But you don't consider it because it's
gender. If they thought they were a fox,
if they believed that they were born in
the ocean of Merck people, you would,
you would say, well, this
guy's out of his fucking mind.
But because he's talking about gender,
he could say, well now I'm a man.
Well now I'm, I'm a woman. I
just turned. I just turned.
So he's in the conversation and in the
middle of the conversation he's like,
I just flipped. Like they asked him
something uncomfortable. I'm jack now.
I just flipped like, oh, you're
fucking crazy. Oh, you're
crazy. You're crazy person.
You believe your male and female back
and forth like ping pong balls. Fuck you.
Okay. Fuck you for putting this on the
air. Fuck you for second. It's seriously,
God dammit. We have time. Jamie's just
tell we're out of time. Goddammit.
Podcast in all the fucking smash
three hours we did it again, sir.
Knocked it out of the park.
It tangentially speaking
is available on iTunes.
Uh, what's your website again? Chris
Ryan. Chris Ryan, Ph d. Dot com. Yeah.
Um,
and the new book will be how long for?
It's all edited and some whacked out
next summer. Yeah. This summer coming up.
Yeah. How many? 16 seven or eight
months? Yeah. Yea. Yeah. All right.
Hopefully before Trump becomes president,
will you leave in December?
We can fucking shove one
more of these bitches. Sure.
Dude, we could talk about it.
I'll, I'll do my homework and we'll
have lots to talk about. All right.
Thanks brother. Appreciate it. As
always fun. Yeah. All right, my friends,
we'll be back soon and until then,
go fuck yourself.
See Ya.
Yeah.